ladies and gentlemen welcome to tim cast
irl i'm your host tim poole who
apparently is a pro-trump youtuber who
incited people on january 6 so saith the
january 6 hearings in a clip aired by uh
what's his name raskin he shows a bunch
of alex jones and salty cracker and then
it shows a clip of me literally reading
a fox news headline that says trump says
protest in dc will be wild and i'm like
trump says the protests are going to be
wild i think he's right and there's
another point where i'm like this is
trump calling for all of his supporters
to be on the ground and they're acting
like i literally said it here's the
funny thing it's like it's the ultimate
transitive property tim pool reads fox
news article
about donald trump
telling his supporters to come on the
ground therefore tim poole is the one
who actually made trump's quote that's
the game they're playing so uh we're
gonna have to talk all about that it's
gonna be a lot of fun plus we got
twitter has officially sued elon musk
and uh i don't know there's a bunch of
stupid news there's a video josh hawley
is questioning this professor and she
and it's the most ridiculous exchange
where he's like who can get pregnant and
she's like people who can get pregnant
he's like do you mean women and she's
like i mean anyone and then they argue
and i'm just like
yeah that to me just shows everything's
imploding so we're going to talk all
about that i'm really excited to show
you the clip of the dangerous
far-right tim pool they say
before we get started head over to
timcast.com
become a member to help support our work
as a member you'll get access to
exclusive segments of this show monday
through thursday 11 pm we called the tim
tim cast after hours show because it is
uncensored last night with dave landau
was
like the funniest we've we've ever had
you know jamie and i we could it was
painfully funny we're laughing so hard
so uh i i definitely recommend it and
we're we're expanding the website into
like a bigger streaming service so we
have a bunch of shows we're preparing
and the ultimate goal is to make it so
that you as a member for 10 bucks will
get access to a huge library just like
any other uh service so don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and today we have an amazing guest we
have adrian curry hi
i'm adrianne curry adrian i'm an amazing
guest
that's right yeah
um i am a aged out pop culture icon from
the early 2000s that's me go google it
we also have libby
hey glad to be here libby emmons editor
of the post millennial
yes yes you are i'm ian crossland what's
up everybody ian crossland.net if you
want to check it out but let's watch the
show and i am also here in the corner as
always pushing buttons i'm delighted to
have a ladies night i love to have
ladies and two is the double blessings
let's get into it all right i i pulled
up this uh story from mediaite oh my
it's going to be a red wedding january 6
committee airs clips of extremists
calling for violence after trump
promised wild protest you ready says
during its hearing on tuesday the
committee first showed former president
donald trump's december 19th 2020 tweet
calling on a supporters to come to
washington the day congress would
certify joe biden's electoral victory be
there will be wild the committee then
showed clips of fringe pro-trump
commentators including alex jones and
tim poole responding excitedly to
trump's call it also showed clips of
extremists calling for violence on
january 6. okay so they do separate alex
jones and me from being extremists i'm
surprised i assume they would have
called alex jones an extremist but they
call us fringe pro-trump commentators um
fringe
at the time of that uh we were the
number one political show on youtube
with 120 million uh views per month uh
well i should say it was around 100 and
then with podcast views
these leftists were making these charts
showing like all the right-wing channels
and then tim poole was like massively
above that
fringe
that's the only thing i take i take
issue with it's not fair people people
are hitting me up and they're like are
you mad they're calling you pro-trump
and i'm like i voted for the guy what do
you like
when they hate you it means you're doing
everything right this one's amazing uh
uh so here's the best part about this
article it says you know clips from
fringe pro trump commentators alex jones
and tim poole but it doesn't actually
quote either of us it quotes matt
bracken and salty cracker
and then you know a cracker again and
then it's like they don't they can't
show anything from me because what i
actually said was so completely
innocuous
and i have the clip for you all right
here
so
let me fix the audio
it always auto plays
i knew the audio so let me uh let me
there's alex jones and i just want to
show you the part where it shows me
talking
because uh some people
you know they swear and we're trying to
be family friendly but here you go
and now donald trump is calling on his
supporters to descend on washington dc
january 6th he is now that was that was
extremism if i've ever seen it and then
there's one more bit let me show you one
more one more bit i'm scared this could
be trump's last stand and it's a time
when he has specifically called on his
supporters to arrive in dc
that's it are you excited i can't tell
that there was like one other clip where
it's like
i read the headline i was like trump
promises a wild protest on dc
on january 6th and they're trying to
discredit you it's not that you said
anything bad they want ev all the
boomers who are watching all 10 of them
to think that you're a bad person
it's it's weird because
that that boomer demographic is it's
it's we we have tons of people who are
in that age bracket who watch the show
and who comment all the time but the
people who do watch that stuff they're
aging out of voting and being involved
in politics i don't understand why
they're chasing after the demographic
that's retiring and handing off the
world to the younger generation that's
all they have left it's the last ones
plugged in in their matrix of lies and
they're struggling maybe if we can just
convince these 10 people that they'll
tell their kids but also it's because
they're not handing it off to the
younger generation they're hanging on to
it they're holding on to the power as as
as tight as they can that's for as long
as they can i mean if you look at i mean
these are my my parents generation and
they still call us all kids you know
they don't they don't act like we're
capable human beings and maybe we're not
but they but we certainly are more than
their geriatric selves are going to be
and the only reason they call you fringe
is because they want to separate you
from the mainstream they want you to be
fringe so they try and they try and
manifest that you are even though you
aren't you have been authored we have uh
yeah it's an othering process we had a
times square billboard for two months i
mean that's that's mainstream that's
fringe before the show we were talking
about the reconciliation if it's even
possible to reconcile going forward and
like if you think that things feel
fractured you know culturally and it's
like before we were all being lied to by
abc nbc cbs they were deciding what the
narrative was everyone had a unified
whether it was a lie or not vision now
it's fractured and uh
i don't know that they're they're
attempting to
to force the narrative but my favorite
thing about this is the people who are
tweeting at me and they're like you
better get your affairs in order tim
like oh it's it's coming i'm like bro
you sound just like the q anon people
who are like it's gonna happen they're
gonna arrest everybody
move those goal posts just keep moving
them q is right yeah i'm like 80 years
dude it's a clip of me reading a fox
news article there was it's a whole the
whole thing the whole january 16th is
like an attempt to to hold on to the
bowl this chart this flipping like
america's changed it's a different place
than it was 50 years ago or 40 years ago
there's the internet and individual
liberty of like individual journalism is
taken off now it's another realm but
they want to like really like smash it
out and just keep it because they think
that it's going to go haywire and it
will fall apart if they don't because
they might be something to that i love
that they're doing this because it was
2020 it was the riots that woke me up
from my former stoner slumber where i
was like wait a minute lighting things
on fire and smashing everything is not
cool man and i started getting mad and
everyone's like well clearly you're
racist i'm like i'm racist because i
don't want to watch people like be
anarchists in the street not even the
cool ones you're like i watched a video
of two white women vandalizing a black
neighborhood like no you're racist right
the black women were pleading with the
white auntie foot to stop it's like no
don't care we saw a video of that over
and over again that kept happening i
think a lot of people are waking up
because of this um bull
poopy
yeah i actually uh i was talking to a
couple people and there are some people
who
are intently watching uh the january 6
hearings who don't like trump but are
like post liberal disaffected liberal
types they don't like trump they don't
want to vote for him but they hate the
establishment
and what i'm they're saying like okay
that was it like when i saw you on there
i was like what
so so there were people who want to
believe that trump is really bad but who
know the show who have watched it and
actually pay attention and they're like
i'm out i've seen leftists on twitter
putting like hahahaha laughing being
like they included tim poole this is
such insane bs it is insane bs and jamie
raskin has this to hold on to he really
needs this to succeed he had very
difficult time the past couple of years
um his son i believe killed himself
horribly and after that i i feel like
jamie raskin is just totally off the
rails he needs this to succeed because
i i don't know how you face that i know
tragedy
he's on the committee he's the one who
played the clips yeah a bunch of people
have told me that i should sue for
defamation because the insinuation is
that these are people encouraging or
inciting that's not what raskin said
raskin said promoting wild protest
promoting is an opinion nebulous term
that doesn't mean anything
yeah i've been through this before these
people are smarmy and they know the
words they use and they use them on
purpose
so there was one outlet that claimed tim
poole pushed a conspiracy theory and do
you know what it really was it was me
debunking it
but by doing a story on it at all it was
pushing that story out to people so i
reached out to a lawyer and they were
like oh but you did push it i mean
that's an opinion statement not a fact
statement and i was like are you kidding
and they were like the fact that you
told the story to people whether you
were in favor of it or not is still
pushing you will lose in court
essentially it's everything's turned
into tmz us weekly and untouched this is
what celebrities used to have to go
through with just gossip and bull crap
and now
gossip and bull crap is our news and
people watch it and they believe it like
what looking at the national enquirer
like elvis had babies with aliens it's
it's seriously that's stupid i i a
friend message to me talking about
something about like the podcast and
how they like don't really get celebrity
news that much anymore and i was like
politics is pop culture it is it is so
we like it's like team sports doesn't
even matter anymore team sports is just
red and blue democrat republican and so
the issue is
because of that mentality
i was talking to this journalist earlier
on twitter about the january 6 committee
and how it's all lies and this is a
person who's like a normie journalist
who is kind of like well you know maybe
so i went into ground.news and i
encourage everyone to do this go to the
blind spotter
and take any blue check journalist you
can find this is a great project for all
of you who want to help create the
database load in any blue check
journalists from nbc from uh the new
york times from cnn from msnbc and all
of them invariably show like an 80 to 90
percent left-wing bias
news from left-wing sources so i started
just sending i'm like to take a look at
this take a look at this sending these
people and they're like whoa these are
nbc reporters and they only consume
leftist sources and then i'm like and
here's ben shapiro 50 50.
yeah i mean when i when i edit in the
morning when i'm like looking for
stories that we want to run
i listen to npr i read the washington
post i read the new york times i read
fox i read politico axios daily wire i
look at literally everything that's out
there and then i try and figure out like
what i think is interesting to talk
about that day but i mean i start the
day with you know jack posobix podcast
and npr and you know the new york times
the daily like this is what i listen to
every morning you're biased yeah i'm i'm
oh my gosh look at that i wasn't even on
the goodness because i deactivated my
twitter that's great
wow i've never seen that before i've
never seen that either that's mostly
because look who i hang out with
you're a far right extremist i can't
believe i'm sitting next to you i don't
i don't know who wrote this this
software because i don't know who's
deciding what's left right in the center
there's uh uh it's ground news and i i
think they're actually pretty code open
what are they formed they're their
account assistant but they're moderates
fully but
well these are just your influencers but
i think the reason it's 96 percent right
is because you probably just post post
millennial all the time oh i do post
post money okay okay right if you get
rid of the post-millennial thing i
wonder what the number would be if you
could filter it that would be cool i
pretty much just post post yeah
sometimes i make little comments is new
york post left or right now
right they're sort of in the middle okay
so it used to be far left everything's
the right now
the left was like an excessive liberal
mag back in the 90s the new york post
yeah the post it was like it was almost
like the national enquirer interesting
oh yeah
kind of a i remember they were tabloidy
yeah msnbc was they took carlson
i've told people this and they don't
believe me and i'm like you don't
realize what life was like
you've had an interesting conversation
recently with uh with a the former
buzzfeed guy uh semaphore
there's this oh yeah ben smith yeah ben
smith and ben smith was trying to make
him out to be a racist and tucker
carlson was like i'm a hundred percent
mad at
white over-educated liberals that's who
i'm pissed about
you know but i think it's interesting
too the thing about where politics has
taken over culture because at a certain
point all of the creators and the
artists started saying that you had to
be activist in your art and they were
all leftist so everything you saw on tv
started being like you know far left
political bias messaging on purpose it's
exhausting it's exhausting
bad art it makes really crappy viewing i
have no tv i barely partake in anything
in society more it's not fun nothing's
fun there's always the message and
everything you're watching and you're
like are you serious like
uh i don't know i'm rejecting girl power
admittedly buried in video games for the
last like
maybe but i cannot take what are you
playing i've been playing warcraft every
day
warcraft uh
like world of warcraft
sir yeah the ultimate escapism it's like
because i cannot watch movies or stupid
i can't take gum acting i can't take
politics there's this like political
like it's not that i don't like
politics in general i don't like
partisan crap where i'm getting fed a
narrative
to to push some agenda i can't it
doesn't interest me it doesn't entertain
me so i'm buried in in like escapism
it's
but this is this is what happens
you're right you know at some point the
activists were like everything is
political so everything needs to be and
it was the left doing that and this is a
this was combined with the the advent of
these microblogs that focus specifically
on one issue
so if you're a gaming website this is
why i think gamergate was like the first
big culture war battle if you're a
gaming website how often can you really
write an article a new video game comes
out so you do all the walkthroughs you
give all your thoughts on the new game
designs you do a couple reviews now what
you gotta wait streamers yeah they
should be doing gaming
they say
the game's racist
oh dead video games right let's talk
about that bill gates bought warcraft
and i had to sign a social
contract like some woke thing to play
with wow yeah they're like you can't
tell people they're naughty names when
they're not doing what they're supposed
to do in a raid and i'm like what like i
can't be
like on i guess it's discord now i'm so
old i almost said ventrilo and be like
yeah i'm like
what you can't yell at people and call
them names i'm like that's like what
world of warcraft is all about
they they ruined it but so what happens
is
the the response to these these woke
lunatics was the anti-woke people
challenging it but they were reactive
these are the people trying to escape
ian and the reason why the culture war
started is because people who are just
like dude i don't want politics i'm just
trying to get away from work and the
news i just want to fight some goblins
and all of a sudden the goblins are
telling me i'm being racist for fighting
the goblins why is this happening and
then they found out that there were
certain prominent feminists who were
going to video game companies and
telling you had to do this and then this
whole thing has just snowballed and it's
continued to the point where now we have
esg i saw a video i'll see if i can pull
it up and explain it later but this guy
was saying that if you if you affect
the children and you make them you
sexually compromise children that they
lose their will
and then as adults they're unable to
combat
anything well they have no boundaries so
you can introduce almost anything to an
abused child like that's why everyone's
anti-grooming right now and that happens
though i mean it's interesting some of
the early drag queen story hour videos
that i saw of like you know parents
bringing their kids the kids would there
were a couple of videos where i saw the
kids would like be pushed toward the
drag queen which is basically like a man
in garish makeup and a dress and a beard
it's sort of like confusing for a kid
the kid would be pushed towards it the
person and then you know would try and
turn away and the parents would push the
kid back you know like it's like saying
break down your did you break down your
barriers you see the video of the old
man and tidy whities twerking to the
little girl
the woman walks up and waves to him and
tells the little girl a little girl
waves to him yeah it looks like he
pooped in them too like he was such a
wreck i i want to uh i want so i want
that clip i want to try and get i'm
going to i want to pitch it out to all
the big uh
advertising billboards
and i was like hey would you guys be
okay putting like a pride event video
clip up i'm gonna say yes but here's the
clip the problem is i don't own it and
so apparently the person who owns it is
very pro what they filmed
so we need video footage of that that's
not that like we could buy or license or
claim or something the video is by this
guy named jocko bullion's first time
ever someone was a prageru video on
instagram no no no the original video
the original video was was someone at
pride celebrating pride oh i'm sorry i
was referencing the guy talking about
sexually compromising children oh
and willingness to support the free
speech willingness to be even interested
they're just incapable of of
understanding the rights of others when
you when you're broken mentally i mean
especially sexually broken i didn't it
didn't happen to me so i don't
personally see it but i see it in others
where it happened to them and it's very
difficult to to continue and to like
know what your boundaries are i yeah i
mean i have friends where this
this is their background and they have
an extremely difficult time
with relationships with understanding
what it's okay to do to them or not
you know i'll just throw out it's very
disturbing and it's hard for them to to
go through life with that i've had over
20 years of therapy i was molested when
i was a kid and i married a guy that was
over 25 years older than me it has a
profound effect on kids and he happened
to be the same age as the dude that you
know
so think it does stuff to you dude and
of course when you're young you're like
no it didn't i'm fine and then you're
sitting on the couch like i'm not okay
oh damn i'm totally okay now
i want that to happen to people you know
yeah but it does and then everyone
celebrates it on twitter look at this
look at what they're doing to these kids
this is great it's acceptance i think
what we're seeing with the internet and
with the start of the culture war is
it's like a sorting algorithm the people
of weak mental fortitude of weak will
are just shuffling along whichever
direction and they're being shuffled off
the cliff yeah and then the people of
strong of strong will and mental
fortitude are resistant and saying no
and that's probably why it's apolitical
why there are liberal people who are now
hanging out with conservatives and
voting for donald trump and being called
french and being called
yeah yeah yeah that's the world most
people agree with these these opinions
but if you're in the cult and you're of
weak will then you're gonna see someone
on the tv say mean things just say
that's a fact period no matter what you
know it's been my experience like i have
friends family that voted for biden and
i never say a word to them i don't like
reprimand them or tell them they're
stupid or but the second someone finds
out i voted for trump but here it comes
and i'm like well biden's just as
horrible like to me and i'm not like
being a butthole to you what like what
is wrong with humanity anymore but they
can't just be cool with each other if
look there are some sane people on the
left but it's the it's the exception not
the rule and that's because uh uh so i
was i was actually uh talking with some
other prominent uh personality this
morning about strategy and stuff and
they were asking me about you know left
and right and i said look man we talk
about this on the show
the right if you look on blind spotter
typically are people who have balanced
views
the left is echo chamber biased cult
they claim the right is the cult but
then you look at ben shapiro and it's
like left and right wing you know on his
blind spot or whatever he consumes news
from all sources he is not in an echo
chamber he is not blind to the facts
like you were mentioning you listen to
npr and do all these things these
journalists in nbc exclusively left-wing
source is not a single right-wing source
and then they post insane things on
twitter totally devoid of facts and they
believe jesse smilet right dude you know
i got flamed on when that story first
came out we're both from
chicagoland i read that story and i'm
like no one goes and walks outside in
that weather no way the gang bangers are
inside smoking there and it was it was
by nbc and the clock never there's like
no humans there never like even when
you're drunk you're not like bro oh
negative 40 polar vortex let's go to
subway said no one in shy town let alone
this is maga country that is not mag
country
and then i said it and everyone's like
you're you're a racist i'm like what how
am i racist like
from there i know this and then it came
out
not a single person said they were sorry
but man did i get executed
all of these stories this is what i like
to bring up you know we can go through
the list of every story that was fake
they believe it every single time well
and then they then they
claim to be arbiters of misinformation
disinformation and truth while they're
the ones who have been pushing this
stuff out there like there was a whole
political story a politico ran a story
and then everybody else picked it up
saying that clarence thomas made these
um claims about code coveted vaccines
and he didn't yes he he didn't at all in
his descent of not taking this
case i think he wanted to take the case
i might be wrong about that but he was
talking about how what the
people who were bringing the suit
said
he said what they said he was quoting
them and everyone was like clarence
thomas is making fake news you know fake
uh
and even when assumptions about it at
first they said clarence thomas posts
false claim x then when they realized
that it was him quoting the the the
plaintiffs i believe he they then change
it to clarence thomas pushes claim of x
and it's like uh he had to cite their
claim in his dissent right like could he
have just not put what they were arguing
he needed to like it's just it's just
happened uh this happened all through
universities in the past few years as
well like a professor would use a word
in order to discuss the word uh usually
it would be like the n word for example
a professor would use
say the word in order to discuss the
word and then would have a whole bunch
of backlash because they were it was
believed that they had used the word but
you have to be able to say a word in
order to discuss it although as regards
the the pride footage you were talking
about we actually had a ton of that
footage that was taken by um beth baish
in toronto and also in um katie davis
court in seattle we have a ton of stuff
that video specifically the one of the
old man twerking for the little girl it
was so cool we have like all these naked
people doing stuff boyfriend of kids in
front of kids
in seattle the issue the issue with that
one is
you get a naked person and you go to an
advertiser they'll say look it doesn't
matter nudity's not allowed okay okay
well but i got his underwear bikini
models are allowed absolutely
so
what what this video is particularly
interesting that shows his old man
twerking in front of a little girl
because one it's in public so it is not
considered to be
out of the bounds of what is publicly
acceptable the man is fully clothed he's
wearing tidy whities you can't tell me
that he's doing anything illegal or if
they say that's not a lot i'll be like
why you have women in bikinis you have
men in speedos but this guy's not
allowed because they know it would be
bad bad bad if they actually did it
imagine times square on the beast a
70-foot screen the biggest you just have
that video everybody would would vote
republican in two seconds if they
watched that what happened to our
society like 10 years ago if some old
dude twerked in front of your kid that
dude would not be alive like that would
not be acceptable for people to like
parade and twerk and shimmy in front of
kids and now everyone's like bring the
kids on down for the shimmy fest and
that came out that was in the washington
post a couple years ago ran an article
about why kink is good to expose kids
it's disgusting
look we're seeing geographic hyper
polarization people in the cities who
oppose that stuff are leaving the cities
and the people who like it or are weak
willed are just sitting there saying
like yeah whatever i don't care so we're
watching these videos and going how
could this be happening it's because
everybody of sound mind is leaving these
areas they're going to texas and they're
going to florida in droves we're
watching for good reason and the outer
suburbs
and we went to west virginia
all my gay friends are like we don't do
the pride anything like they're like we
used to on the weekend like 10 years ago
hey we had a little weekend they're like
it has just turned into debauchery and
you know like i can be gay without a
community of people like good job i'm
like that's funny
oh man this is more babies this is why i
say stuff like uh
like civil war
because people don't understand the
world views are so incredibly divergent
that you you people like people
can't live together anymore so
from what i've seen in my own eyes i
went to northern ireland i went to
belfast i didn't see the troubles i was
too young but you look at i mentioned
often the peace wall
that separated you know the groups that
were fighting to try and stop the
violence on one side there's a monument
painting celebrating people who murdered
a bunch of other people who are like at
a restaurant like some people are taking
a restaurant some dudes jumping just gun
them down and the other side's like yeah
you did it that's deep tribalism when
one side of the wall says we are the
true sons of israel and the other side
says we stand with palestine i'm like
what does that have to do with the like
uk the irish republic protestantism you
know catholicism browns
it is just
rival so when you have people
they don't care
what the truth is they care that their
enemies burn and when you're in a cult
this is why i think that the biggest
threat is the establishment left and
many leftists they don't care for the
truth they don't seek out the truth they
believe lies they don't care that they
believe lies they just want pain for
them also organized religion man it's
all this is they're trying to organize a
religion around this stuff and any time
you're willing to believe something
without proof is insanity it's dangerous
and if you become zealous in your
beliefs then you become a danger you
know what i'll give you this the vatican
is corrupt beyond anything in the world
i was born and raised catholic i do
believe in god but you do hit some
points with organized religion corrupt
people take over anything they can where
they can manipulate the sheep take all
their money and buy themselves
helicopters i think the vatican's been
doing that for a really long time now
it's um davos group affiliated
individuals that the mentality of these
people is that i will tell you this i
have wined and dined with some of these
people i've been on rooftop parties and
their attitude is look someone's got to
work at mcdonald's and that doesn't mean
that some people you know they're just
not smart enough no no what they're
saying is we don't care if you're smart
we don't care if you're stupid we need
someone to make our burgers so whether
you're right for it or not we will make
it you
keeping people down putting themselves
in pitches of power because these are
people who don't care about meritocracy
as exemplified by everything in the
culture war it's about protecting
themselves and their core group and
their assets regardless of what is
beneficial to humanity regardless of
what is true
last night i was thinking about drone
delivery and like okay biggest problem
with government what if there was a
revolution we had to reform a new
government then we'd have to be if we
were the ones in charge we'd have to
figure out where the resources are going
and make sure everyone has enough and
all of a sudden you realize we don't
have enough resources we don't have the
drone delivery like the the you will own
nothing and be happy and you'll get
everything through drones like if you
order something from amazon.com or our
website and you live in like sub-saharan
africa a drone will get thrown through
the stratosphere and orbitally drop off
your goods and then go back imagine
those going to red states people would
be blowing them out of the sky
they do get shot they do get shot so
that gives me it gives me a little bit
of a glimmer of okay violation that's
like an fa crime maybe shooting them
down yeah they're aircraft maybe we
could organize society maybe it could be
fixed or or resolved but then the other
part of me is just like dude it just
feels like we're on an avalanche headed
towards world economic forum takeover
where we're all like or not all of us
but the useless class which is what
you've all know harare calls these
people that are just sitting around
playing video games collecting
unemployment
yeah i've been there i don't understand
it i was part of that um that they just
are going to sit in the metaverse on
psychedelics that are pharmaceutically
administered be getting government
support and and maybe they're harvesting
their body here no not having kids
of course they'll just be there until
this is uh are you have you played
fallout one or they'll use their
reproductive organs they might surrogacy
and stuff like that so have you played
fallout one yes so uh there's
the big game that was like
groundbreaking was fallout 3 and it's a
it's a fallout series is about a
post-apocalyptic post-nuclear war and um
i think it's part one spoiler alert for
the 30 or whatever year old game uh or
older it's like a doom spoiler alert
yeah right so the main villain is this
uh there's a thing called the forced
evolutionary virus that the idea was if
nuclear war happened they would give
people this virus to genetically modify
them so they could survive nuclear war
it turned them into super mutants
who were androgynous and unable to have
children
so you come out of the vault and like
some human survived and the main villain
at the end says
your genetics can't be allowed to
continue but i won't kill you if you if
you if if you'd like i can sterilize you
and let you let you live your life and
that's like one of the endings
so what i think we may be seeing
you know look
you can't you can't look at someone like
bill gates who goes on on stage like a
ted event and says we need to reduce
population and think he's not trying to
reduce population he is yeah he is true
we need to reduce population now trust
me to feed you and give you drugs yes
bill gates but outside of like people
being concerned about drugs or whatever
do you so when he what he was talking
about is like if we improve technology
improve healthcare we're going to see
people have less and less kids because
technological advance advancements
correlate with people having smaller
smaller families
i'm not going to get into the crazier
conspiracies about what he may be doing
with farmlands or anything like that
because he's buying a lot of farmland
but i'll say this do you think he
doesn't consider
um sex ed
and like uh safe like prophylactics and
stuff as part of that campaign of course
he does of course he's thinking like how
can i get people to not have kids in
africa so
right and and so uh obviously a lot of
people like well that's okay right okay
what about when you get in the territory
of supporting organizations that
advocate for say like sterilizing
children saying like you should give
them puberty blockers which
has a high chance of or a decent chance
of you know uh inhibiting their ability
to reproduce once they get older or
their desire and they lie to these
families and kids and say oh it's
reversible
let me let me pull up this story from
timcast.com
law professor says senator hawley's
question about pregnancy opens trans
people to violence during senate
judiciary committee hearing i watched
this video and i said i i saw two things
i saw the right wing sharing the c-span
video saying can you believe this i saw
the left wing sharing the same video
saying can you believe this the left
overtly supporting this woman and the
right overtly supporting holly let me
see if i can i can play this professor
you said several times you've used a
phrase i want to make sure i understand
what you mean by it you've referred to
people with a capacity for pregnancy
would that be women
many women cis women have the capacity
for pregnancy many cis women do not have
the capacity for pregnancy um there are
also trans men who are capable of
pregnancy as well as non-binary people
who are capable of pregnancy so this
isn't really a women's rights issue it's
uh we can recognize that this impacts
women while also recognizing that it
impacts other groups those things are
not mutually exclusive senator hawley so
your view is i i got a pause right there
because it's this thing they do on the
left like aoc has done this where they
do this trail
senator hawley like aoc did that with
the refugees thing
legal asylees are not refugees it's like
dude okay man come on make your point
this right then is about what
so i want to pause right here and just
say this they're talking about women's
rights they're talking about pregnancy
holly asks a straightforward question
what do you mean by people who can get
pregnant and she says a bunch of people
he says okay so it's not a women's
rights issue which is a legitimate and
fair question
it's a pregnant people issue and the
woman still gives him the business yeah
this also happened uh ilhan omar was
talking about pregnant persons
um you had javier becerra with
hhs talking about birthing people you
had corey bush discussing an extremely
difficult birth that she had with her
children uh talking about how she was a
birthing person talking about black
birthing bodies things like
and i think that it actually um it helps
to drive people away from this argument
because they look at it and they're like
no you mean women and everyone's like no
we mean something sort of amorphous or
as macy gray said it's a vibe yeah i
hate to say this that's what you said
yeah she said it was a title yeah
yeah she walked back her comments that
women were you know adult human females
and instead decided to say that being a
woman they're talking about total
shortages i say we need them do you
think any of this would exist if
everyone was hungry do you think someone
would yell at me about me misgendering
them if i had a loaf of bread and they
did not and was offering some none of
that would exist
none of this would exist adrienne i
think they i think they will hopefully
so anyway well then you didn't know and
then i think they would probably steal
your i think they would probably steal
your bread good luck
there was uh there was actually over the
over the weekend um
in new york city a 14 year old boy was
stabbed on the subway on 137th street
stabbed to death by a group of girls
that were trying to rob him
whoa oh new york so here's what i was
saying the other day
i want to put on skate contests
obviously the contest we would put on
would adhere to a male female standard i
we i wouldn't do mixed you know events
and i'm talking to some people like okay
what if we did an event
and we were like it'll be a normal
contest we'll find a good park we will
pay for the construction of a small
skate park we donate the skate park
afterwards to the community and then you
know we get sponsored stuff help cover
the costs well the men's division and
women's division and i was told a lot of
people aren't going to want to come
because of the political implications
and i was like we'll do it we'll we'll
do a good cash prize like i think it'll
be okay and they're like no i don't know
and then i was like 10 grand
okay now they'll all show they'll all
show up so these people who are like
posting these instagram videos saying
things like you know we gotta we gotta
be
respect the trans women who are
competing against biological females
because it's all here and then i'll be
like for 10 grand would you come and
participate in my event we don't allow
that they would say you bet we should
may i have another yeah because these
people don't actually care about
principle they care about money and the
reason why they're supporting these
movements is because the corporations
and the sponsors are saying this is what
we want if you want to stay on payroll
well if i offer up a counter payroll
they will change their position because
like i said these are people of weak
mental fortitude of weak will this is
what i've been saying for years about um
arts culture in the u.s so when you're
an artist and you're a young person you
want to make money for your art and so
you uh submit for grants you submit for
prizes and all of these things and most
of the prizes are like if you you know
these prizes are open to non-binary
genderqueer
blah blah blah blah and you have to like
go on and on with whatever your identity
is they're open to your identity they're
open to
plays about given identities or what
have you and so
if you change that if you start offering
uh prizes and grants for
other kinds of values you will get work
that represents those other values the
only reason you're getting so much of
this garbage is because that's what's
being funded so artists just do what
they're artists do what they're told i
mean that's the dirty secret about
artists for the most part they will do
what they're told so long as they get
paid to do it so just pay them to do
something else and they'll they'll take
their talent and do whatever you want
i'm sure you have some of what i have
which is all these famous faces that say
one thing and then they're like
hey i agree everything you say adrien oh
dude yeah and i'm like you
i cannot say the word
yeah i hate those people and they're
like i hate them so much i secretly
agree with you i just can't say anything
publicly and you're like you know what
if everyone would just talk
if everyone just speak up speak their
piece then none of this would be
happening it would end tomorrow
no one has to be quiet
i want to show you this comic that's
been going around kate andrews tweeted
this taylor silverman retweeted it and
it's a woman being burned at the stake
and the guy says i completely agree with
you oh my gosh gosh accurate well i
can't say it publicly because i need to
make that money i'm like cool can we put
that on your tombstone i was a coward
and i needed that cash gonna make money
do you i don't even i i have a bunch of
like prominent uh uh i should say a
handful of like la celebrities actors
you know movies tv show musicians they
hit me up and they're like man you know
like i i i agree with you so much and
i'm like dude you've got more followers
than me
you could just
you don't even need to say something
like i support donald trump you could
just very simply be like whoa what's
this story about can anyone explain it
to me just to at least make sure your
fans know it's happening and then you're
like oh i don't know it's just a story
from abc about trans kids i just was
sharing it i don't know
the ones that aren't activists that only
like posted the black square because
everyone was like pressuring them the
ones that just does that like you know
i'm obliged to do this one thing or this
two thing but they're not activists
they're all
like us they're just cowards
i know something about the black square
too it's like if you posted the black
square then um and you were like a white
person then that was an issue too
because you were taking up space oh i
got bullied i did it and like two
seconds later i took it down i was like
this is stupid but you got bullied
either way you got bullied for not doing
it and bullied for doing it oh i've been
on a tour of a few very
stupid yeah you just gotta not care like
uh it's funny um
the the the the patriots.win which is
the big trump forum they routinely
insult me they call me a [ __ ] and a
bunch of other names because i'm like a
fence sitter and i don't give trump
enough support i don't believe him suck
but it's funny because i made a video
and i said i said something like you
know you want to know how you know the
left is a cult for one you can look at
the journalists and see they only
consume left-wing news but on the
quote-unquote far right whatever they
want to call it trump supporters will
call me a [ __ ] and a bunch of other
names but still be like if he's got a
good guest on will watch and they posted
saying like tim thanks us for calling
him a cuck because it proves not a call
i'm gonna
vote every single tim
insult now on patreon
you have
the thing is like i don't i'm not going
to cry about trump supporters being mad
at me i just bet yeah they're mad at me
i'm not going to cry about leftists
being mad at me it's the internet right
exactly everyone's mad at me the left
doesn't doesn't have any and like uh and
this is again when i say the left i'm
speaking generally not every single
person
but they have this
they can't tolerate any deviation from
the hive it's
outright creepy i mean we've said that
ad nauseam at this point but that's the
reality well the interesting thing too
is they say that it's all the counter
culture right like they push pride and
all of these things and they
it's all framed out as though it's a
counter-cultural movement but it
actually is the dominant culture and it
demands adherence just like any dominant
culture before it well so so here's a
meme i just want to share with you guys
and it's the skinner meme and he says
uh he says maybe i am an npc no having
the same opinions as celebrities and
major corporations while repeating every
media talking point verbatim is what
real people do maybe i'm the npc yeah
he almost broke free he thought about it
for a second and said no no when amazon
and walmart say it that's edgy i think i
think that jordan peterson would tell
you that this is because these people
are possessed by ideology they are not
you lose a good dose of your humanity
when you give yourself over to an
ideologue position and you lose like the
you very much lose the ability to think
independently and i think that's why we
see the ground news where so much of the
left is just possessed by only
supporting the left wing and the hive
mind like tim is talking about it's 100
ideology i want to i want to um
i want to go back to the point you
brought up a moment ago about bread
and would any of this be happening if
people were starving
and i'll say this
feminism can only exist in a secured
society yes yes so uh and this is i was
reading evolutionary psychology and
evolutionary biology and like the rise
of gender roles
and gender roles break down when there
is no pressure on genders to pursue
these roles so in the in the early
humans were struggling to survive era
the women are the most important thing
every guy but one could die and the
society survives if the women die you
are in serious trouble so keeping the
women safe within the community was
important this eventually turns into
women just stay home and men go out and
work and do the dangerous jobs men go to
war women run you know the house and
stuff but once there's no more war once
there's no bears once there's no direct
threat
there's nothing that there's there's no
danger so the women are not in danger to
leave and go out and start you know
being a part of society so this is not
me saying that gender roles are good or
are
prescribing any moral um positive or
negative i'm saying this is literally
what the literature i was reading says
and so the issue then is today we're so
fat we're so happy we're so speak for
yourself well i mean
you're fat
i mean
i'm not even happy
i mean well look look look
our borders used to be secure they're
not now our country used to be well-fed
and this luxury these good times made
weak men which resulted in a weak
society and things start breaking right
so i think you know to your point if uh
if people were starving
if there was a conflict
maybe what we're starting to see
happening right now they're saying
there's going to be a food shortage come
fall the harvest is going to be really
bad they're telling farmers to stop
farming which is the craziest thing
another riding over it and shooting at
farmers right
people are going to be starving and
maybe it is like some kind of
inevitability when a society gets woke
it goes broke and a broke society has no
food which then struggles and is forced
to get rid of the woman unless you're a
prepper and a traditional woman who
married a traditional man who's the man
of the house i am protected and i will
be fed and you will be
now we're good out here do you guys
think there will be an emperor an
america like that the republic will fall
in an empire will form some something is
always
always formed always but i want to say
you said morally you don't want to talk
about like traditional relationships i
used to be one of those i'm a feminist i
want to wear the pants i was miserable i
was a miserable i can't say the word bad
words want to come out of my mouth i'm
trying people ladies
and now that i've like embraced my role
as a woman and i have a man who's a man
i feel dude i'm baking cakes and i'm
making pizza i love it and i'm
decorating stuff and i'm so happy and i
like being a chick and i i was more
unhappy trying to be a dude like i could
do anything a man can do no i can't i
can't even open a pickle jar different
things
that's great very different yes it's
great do you think women i've heard that
women have better pain tolerance though
oh yeah because we have to have babies
so regarding cooking you think women are
more drawn to being around hot
temperatures because it doesn't hurt
them as much that's uh oven bites and i
can probably deal with those better than
men yeah those are like almost third
degree burns but they're matching now
yeah thank you
thank you i can't be a handshaker
anymore i did end up with a much
different view of womanhood after uh
after i got pregnant and after my son
was born
was drastically different um well for
one thing
you guys have heard me say this before
like i'm very i'm very glad to be a mom
i'm very grateful every day that you
know i have my son and whatever um
but i just uh
it became a very different
it just became a very different view of
womanhood in terms of like prior to that
i was raised by feminists i was raised
by two feminists a stepmother and a mom
in different houses but they were both
very feminist and i had this idea that
you know you have to get your graduate
degree before you have kids and you have
to like pursue your career and all of
this kind of stuff and that's like the
stupid idea it turns out because i would
have way more kids now if i hadn't so
many of my friends were way too happy
you know like i yeah i mean i had my son
when i was 35.
um
if i had started having kids before i
went to graduate school like graduate
school didn't make me happy i don't even
know if i learned anything you know like
i furthered the things i already knew
but i didn't need grad school i
certainly didn't need the debt i ended
up with and then they don't tell women
that 35 and above is geriatrics that's
right it's so rude no it's not even rude
though it's true
so we're lying to women going you can
have kids later and you can endanger
yourself and your children so you could
be selfish while you're young and it's
like our bodies are designed to do that
bounce back when we're younger and as we
get older you know we get it gets harder
and harder so you watch someone start
kids in their twenties and then they're
third yeah and no lifestyle no like
hedonistic about dress lifestyle is
worth those lies no
no but i mean it's tough to tell someone
don't do what i did
like hey i partied hard in my 20s don't
do that
you be you don't get to enjoy the wild i
totally still could have partied hard in
my twenties which i did
uh and still had kids sooner be a
midwife cause like parents open the
garage
right like still because yeah i did all
kinds of crazy stuff in my 20s and i
don't regret it but i could have started
having kids sooner this is uh one of the
one of the greatest things in terms of
reducing population tell women to be men
tell them to go work and be miserable
but but the idea is like
they say you can have it all you can
have a family and be the ceo and that's
just not true it's not even easy for a
dude to do all of these things very few
people are ceos
i should say a fortune 500 a big
successful companies right it is it is
hard to balance everything and what
we're seeing now is
for for four guys who are trying to have
families while they're while their wives
are working and they have kids even
they're struggling like which parent is
going to watch the kids oh the kids got
to go to a public school as daycare
basically so
when it was women were raising the kid
it was easier for the guy to succeed
when both are trying to succeed in the
exact same space neither there's an old
i think it's an old japanese saying a
person who tries to catch two rabbits
will catch neither something like that
that's basically what we're seeing so
look i you it could be the dad who wants
to stay home find whatever it can be the
women who want to stay home with the
kids but someone needs to be in charge
of family yeah that's definitely true
and women are better at it i'm sorry and
that's why they i would try to erase us
now you know like you don't exist you
know why i think women are better at it
because women actually produce food for
their babies yeah so like could you
imagine if like the mother gave birth to
like twins and then within a few months
like i'm going back to work it's like
just give the baby's formula i guess
it's like okay well you know
breastfeeding is an option what formula
there is none right now
so i'm not saying like i know certain
circumstances like um what what nurses
were a thing right under the same thing
for a very long time women have the
natural ability to feed their kids not
all of them but more more so than men do
therefore
there's advantages for women being in
charge of the family there's this
interesting thing that i was i was
actually talking to my son about
recently um there's surrogacy right
there's all of these things where he was
talking to me about how there's going to
be uh
pods there's going to be like pods where
children are gestated in pods and i was
like so this would be the manufacturer
of motherless children like what do you
think about that and we were talking
about it and i was like you know i think
it makes a lot of sense the way that we
have it now where a child is connected
to their mother as soon as they're born
because they've been connected this
whole time and being pregnant gives you
um
gives you sort of like a feeling of
protection of the child as soon as
somebody's hormones yeah you know you
feel there is more of a connection and i
i think probably will end up in a place
where we have children gestated in you
know
sex robot style pods you know these
kinds of things i'm i'm sure that we're
heading in that direction um i hope i'm
dead by that
but i think that i think that we lose
our humanity and i think a lot of this
is an anti-humanist movement it's like
we hate ourselves
so much we hate everything that we came
from that we want to destroy it and we
want to destroy our connection to one
another what was alex jones saying that
they want the elites want to ascend
like they want to upload their
consciousness and like be immortal this
is transhumanism yeah i talked to zoltan
eastbound about this a couple of years
ago and that's you know that's a i lost
the interview somewhere but um i know
instead of running it it's somewhere
literally somewhere i can't
mathematically calculate anything other
than transhumanist future because like
you look at the neanderthals and they
were vicious they would steal human
children and eat them when the when the
they would eat children yeah they would
they were like tomcats so humans hunted
them to extinction essentially this is
one theory uh that i've been listening
to lately but like
we evolve and become semi-autonomous
robots that don't need to consume food
anymore humans are severe danger to our
species because they eat and destroy
their surroundings so we need to wipe
them out like that's the that's i don't
see any other path first unless unless
we have total destruction right unless
we unless we have uh total collapse of
society and then all of this stuff
disappears and we're strong survivors
yeah yeah
right and then we're in a situation
where we don't have pods because we
don't even have the resources to build
these pods
like uh plastic surgery to retain youth
that didn't work everyone morphs into
the same face look at instagram and then
they they're trying with the fountain of
youth i think in sweden they're funding
all that research to try to extend life
that's not working so now what is the
upload elon musk i don't trust you
imagine imagine it this way yeah this is
what's happening right now whether
intentional or otherwise
imagine there's like a giant mountain
and the water is just rising every hour
by one foot the strongest people climb
to the top of the mountain with no
problem but most people can't even get
up the base and the water just floods up
the weaker people get engulfed by it get
wiped out and the stronger people
narrowly survive then the water recedes
everyone comes back down and goes about
their life what's happening now with the
reporting on ukraine and the famines and
the war and all that is that it's going
to be countries in in sub-saharan africa
it's going to be parts of turkey it's
going to be lebanon countries in the
middle east that will have no food
because they import their food from
ukraine and russia so outside the united
states it's going to be cataclysmic
for us
with the loss of access to their
resources to many of these countries
resources and the labor they produce for
us it'll get fairly bad so there will be
it's it's
i guess you can call it whatever your
idea is there is a culling that is about
to occur i don't know if it's going to
be like mass death or anything like that
but they they said during covet 250
million people would starve due to the
shutdown of the economy something like
that is is going to happen
did that happen that didn't happen i
think i think masturbation happened
during covet yeah i don't know i don't
know if they all died but i'm pretty
sure you know you want to look at that
there was some hungriness yeah right
that was that's like it's real something
yeah would it that's wild what's
happening
i feel like that's how humanity always
was we were always culling out the weak
and the weirdos so we didn't have to
deal with this like first world coddling
of everyone where we're all surviving
and i hate saying it i don't want to see
anyone get hurt but maybe that's why
we're where we're at is science yeah
it's no longer the strongest now it's
the most adaptable well it's always
really been the most adaptable you just
used to need strength to adapt now you
need money and it's the rich kids that
are born into it they can afford a
helicopter to get up above the flood it
could be it could be that an unnatural
consequence just in evolution is that
wokeness and hive mind
like necrosis it emerges when a society
becomes new gluttonous it may just be an
emergent phenomenon that because
everybody is well fed and what what
what's this so i found some articles
about starvation and they're a little
unsettling so in haiti a bunch of
inmates starve to death but that could
be just a prison thing the u.n is saying
that 345 million people are marching to
the brink of starvation however much you
want to trust you we saved grandma who
cares well yeah but we do you're not
even safe exactly we didn't die or say
that anymore
yeah and you're not even allowed to say
that anymore you're not allowed to say
that we should have protected the people
who needed protection the most because
that's there's a name for it it's like
some kind of theory that you're not
supposed to anyway lots of people are
headed towards starvation putin was
prepared to starve parts of the
developing world according to a yale
historian a month ago so i forgot what i
was talking about what's up coming up
starvation
no that was before i started talking
about something okay sorry i didn't mean
to distract i was just reading about sri
lanka we've got a room full of chicks
dude
i'm sorry
we're going all view over here what you
were talking about i want to talk about
like becoming robots because i have no
idea i would definitely talk about
becoming robots i'm fascinated by
transhumanism i will be the first uh
maybe not the first i want to make sure
it doesn't kill you yeah he's doing it
hell
it and the changing of the world i think
it's possible but it's also possible
that when a society has no external
threats
and the weak survive the weak way down
the society causing a collapse it's very
much at the fourth turning it's not
intentional
it's possible it's intentional but it
could just be that too many gluttonous
weak people disrupt the system and cause
suffering which results in a natural
sort of like
culling
the society gets weighed down you know
it's like a boat can carry people but
you put too much people on it or someone
gets too fat the boat sinks yeah and
then the people who are fit and strong
swim to safety and the people who aren't
don't make it all the way bad but you're
right
you're right yeah that's true well this
is how you arrive always worked and we
we take offense to it because it kind of
hurts our feelings and i do think that a
civilized society should protect the
weakest members like old people and
developmentally disabled people but if
you don't have that level of
sophistication anymore it goes very much
back to this primal
i need to survive survival of the
fittest and it's brutal like what
percent would you be willing to kneecap
your civilization to protect the weakest
two you know 78
so look
we know that if deer are left unchecked
they destroy like the the ecosystem they
just eat like crazy so when there's deer
season it's like a certain amount of
deer and like the males are allowed to
be killed and things like that we we
know culling is important we know about
feral hogs people getting helicopters
and gun them down there's too many
they're destroying the landscape and
they'll they'll cause serious problems
they're not controlled and a lot of this
has to do with the decimation of wolf
populations and the in the imbalance
with predators so we have to fill that
role
humans don't have natural predators
what so so what effectively puts
pressure on humans i think ultimately
there doesn't need to be any kind of
global leader who decides to kill people
to call civilization because weak people
eventually just
sink the ship
and then the stronger people have to
suffer suffer because of it but then
ultimately it's just a natural
phenomenon well if this is the titanic
since i'm a
traditionalist foreign children on the
boats first see you later dude
well
i think what's been happening is that
powerful elites in the u.s have watched
the ship hit the iceberg and are
stealing the the fine china
jumping out definitely no stealing the
china you're right jumping on the
lifeboats and being like it's just a
routine test of the lifeboats don't
worry about it it's fine they're gone
the biden family is definitely like that
they've they've just got their you know
they're reaching out and stuff and stuff
in their pockets believe the people that
defend them it's kind of crazy right
okay i loved bill clinton i had a
autographed book by him and when i found
out all the
crap about my daddy's from arkansas he's
from arkansas everything there is named
after bill clinton so that's what i was
grown up with yeah and i looked at that
book and i'm like disgusting and i threw
it away i gotta i gotta pull up this
story uh let's talk about the collapse
of society here we go from yahoo news
starbucks is closing 16 stores across
los angeles portland seattle and other
cities due to a high frequency of
challenging incidents
what they mean is employees were being
attacked people were doing drugs in the
bathroom and let me just say this is one
of the most epic get woke go brokes
because four years ago starbucks got
attacked by a bunch of woke activists
and announced our bathrooms are now open
and everyone said dude your bathroom's
open to the public it's going to be a
disaster of drug use this is a problem
and they're nasty and it's so bad last
month starbucks said we may have to
close our bathrooms but that would have
drawn the ire of the far left activists
so what did they do shut the whole store
down we're done yeah
yeah i mean if you go into a starbucks
bathroom in a city they are disgusting
their coffee is disgusting i can't
believe people drink it it tastes like
burgers
yes but the starbucks nitro cold brew
it's pretty good it is the best i've
never gotten to that point i do a french
press of my own stuff every day and i
don't drink that burnt crab unless i'm
in an airport cracked out like oh my god
cold brew though
i haven't tried it i if i try it and
you've lied to me for breakfast i have a
can uh is all i have is a can of well i
have more but so when i wake up i have a
can of nitro cold brew with heavy cream
and it's like a chocolate milkshake
almost
peanut butter powder wait how many
calories is in that there's like 10
calories in the cold brew and then i
think like 80 in the cream 50 per
tablespoon of heavy whipping cream 50
per tablespoon okay so maybe a hundred
about 100 that is not worth those
calories i like cupcakes
if i'm gonna eat all that crab i'm gonna
have a cupcake i
have lost 30 pounds
with your coffee breakfast with my well
i do have eggs so i'll have coffee and
then i record so after i record my first
segment i usually have like eggs and
bacon or something
but i cut out all the cupcakes and all
of that evil dispelling a myth the
calories aren't actually in the food a
calorie is a measurement of heat that's
produced when your body breaks the food
apart so you're actually producing the
calories i stopped eating cups cakes and
stuff like that when i ran out of time
to do a lot of baking i used to do a lot
of baking which i kind of missed doing i
was making these like tall like eight
layer cakes but mini like really like
what i do like really tall like top hats
good for you right i make layers they're
so good and i have these like little
tiny pants they're like this we're women
and once a month we need cupcakes and
sugar because there's a difference
and if we don't have it you'll die so
all men out there give us
sugar you need like a steak yeah
i don't it all depends
on the
frankly you need the steak during you
need the chocolate yeah but is it the
chocolate or the sugar because
chocolate's really good for you
i love chicken cacao without sugar just
pure bitter tastes like coffee beans
kind of i like just
i'm a super health nut so clearly i'm
not like sitting around eating sugar all
day like all i do is work out and count
calories so when i do
do something bad like my husband and i
will eat like three pizza and go get a
huge thing a krispy kreme and just eat
the whole box i love how it's like
society is collapsing and starbucks is
shutting down but their coffee is bad
anyway yeah yeah it tastes like burnt
butthole i can't drink it
my first job was an ice cream
oh well i was when i was starting mines
the social network we were uh we would
work and i'd go to a starbucks oh i see
you'd do that no i just i scooped ice
cream i don't know i would i do think
that it's very disturbing to see the
infrastructure that was created with the
with the wealth that our culture had
just completely collapsed so here's my
my idea which man i want to do all these
awesome things i just need people who
can help do them uh i i just buy
starbucks they sacrificed the well-being
of their employees to appease the woke
mob they knew it was going to make their
stores more dangerous they knew that it
was going to welcome in people to do
drugs and be belligerent and violent
they didn't care and now they have to
shut down 16 stores disrupting all of
these employees because they don't care
now some people have said oh but they
pay well and things okay fine you know
what i want to do i talked about before
i want to open a coffee shop right next
to a starbucks and i want to do to
starbucks what starbucks is accused of
doing other shops subsidize everything
make it so cheap that starbucks can't
afford to be open and then tell those
employees come work for us and we'll pay
you better and we'll treat it like a
co-op
we won't play this garbage where we let
weirdos in the bathroom while you're
working you'll be in charge and here's
my favorite part if you are working at
my coffee shop when we open it and a
customer is being rude feel free to cook
them out and tell them never to come
back i don't i don't play the stupid
game where the customer is always right
if they're being belligerent to the
employees who are making the food
is that true at starbucks you're not
allowed to kick people out if they suck
i don't know if starbucks does that the
idea is that the customer is always
right and most of these big corporate
stores are like just be demure and
apologize no
no it's it's it's it's your store you're
trying to do people a favor you're
providing a service we're all equals
here if someone's giving you the
business you say look just have a nice
day you can go i want a place where the
employees are not going to be stepped
all over for the corporate agenda it's
also really not fair to have the because
employees like at starbucks and whatever
you have to clean the bathroom like
everyone's sort of on a shift to clean
the bathroom exactly and it's so nasty
to do that like i used to work at an
obon pain a million years ago and we
always had to switch off who was
cleaning the bathroom women's bathrooms
are the worst it was just it was it was
not it was just one bathroom right and
like random people would come in there
and they would defecate all over the
place and we would have to clean it up
and that's just really unhealthy on the
wall sometimes oh yeah i worked at acme
like my stomach is turning right now
like just remembering the experience
just having to clean that bathroom after
like random
crazy i'm sorry i'm four years old and
everything poop makes me laugh can i
just gross it looks so gross i just
wanna i just wanna ask this question uh
i wanna make this point actually you
guys up at the shopping cart test no oh
yeah i love it it's this idea that the
shopping cart is the ultimate test of
like whether a person can function in
society
returning the shopping cart to the cart
corral
is a minor task
minor inconvenience it has no reward you
know it's the right thing to do you
should do it
most people don't most people don't yeah
they just well depends on where you're
at i suppose so you know where i was in
where i lived in uh the philly suburbs
you'd go to the walmart and it's just
carts everywhere and so someone comes
out and people just like they put the
cart to the side and i'm like just
return the car it takes five seconds
it's the right thing to do but then you
gotta think about these bathrooms
when when you mention people getting on
the wall and stuff yeah what the heck
i've seen that think about there's a
video there's a video of a guy going in
an elevator
and he pisses on the elevator buttons
causing a malfunction and then he panics
and then i'm just like what is wrong
with people that they're like i'm going
to piss on an elevator button freaking
mark in their territories
someone goes into a bathroom like no one
can see me now i'll just ruin someone's
day but is that like they they have ibs
the irritable bowel syndrome and they
can't handle it and they're like ah they
can't make it to the toilet and it flies
out
i lived there for a few
but if you do the squat thing right and
you're not going to sit on the public
toilet like how hard is it to just clean
up after yourself like why don't people
do that but then you're just cleaning up
urine and someone's like oh look at this
clean seat and then they sit in your pee
because you think you've done some
service to society
clean up after me of a self-cleaning
public bathroom leave a bathroom the
whole toilet
moves like it spins around there's like
two toys and spins around and on the
other side it's like got scrubbers and a
spray in it oh yeah and then it's like
which goes in in france in spain
in europe they have like public urinals
i think they're like these uh uh
it's it's uh elevated off the ground so
you can see feet and then it's like a
spiral and you walk to the middle of the
spiral and there's a hole in the ground
you piss into and they did that because
homeless people and drunks were just
peeing everywhere so they made these
weird little things i think they're in
europe they might be i think i think
they might have those in like seattle
maybe i think in india you have to pay
to use the public toilet everywhere in
europe i'm glad you brought up the guy
peeing on the elevator buttons because
like i love michael malus but he
believes people can govern themselves
[Laughter]
okay malice people will pee on the
elevator buttons and get themselves
stuck in the elevators i think he's so
smart he forgets that most everyone else
is a [ __ ]
alice is a great friend and i'm a big
fan he's a very smart guy yeah but he
needs rules he often says that uh how
could anyone be pessimistic when you see
how dumb these people are and my
response that is yes they're dumb but
many dumb people can be dangerous like a
zombie horde you know what i mean yeah
or stampede right or twitter
and dumb people can get frustrated
easier when they don't understand they
can tend towards frustration which leads
towards anger and then they can become
very very malicious and dangerous
this is what we're seeing right now so
here's what i think is happening
strong-willed people inquisitive people
and smart people they they know what's
happening in the world they turn on the
news and they're like is that true and
they check and they go oh that wasn't
true just lied then you have people who
are just dumb as a box of rocks going
like whoa jesse smilet and they go on tv
and they're like this is not a debate
what happened to jesse smilet is so
wrong and then the host goes like i
agree and this is like these people are
as dumb as dumb wait a minute was that
the dead named person that was the dead
i don't know what you're talking about
the dead named person i was making a
random vague analogy no you awoken a
demon in my brain of memory
i'm like wait the artist formerly known
as prince yes that's who's that's what
we're going to call when i was going on
his page concerts i would watch the
people play and then people would be
like
i'm like what are they screaming and
like everyone's clapping to get i'm like
what is this like call this this weird
a this this creature that's being formed
in the sea of humans like i don't i
would just like watch
and like even if i loved it i wasn't
going to be like
you know like that's been with us the
whole time i mean that's dionysian
that's like you know ancient rites of
sensory overload
you know we have that you know i i i i
don't know i don't see anything wrong
with that with like enjoying that to an
extent and
um and getting all crazy like that is
the mindless clap because if you do that
at a concert ideally you're not doing
that ever you know in your accounting
department people are animals i wonder
if those are the people that are like
just on autopilot that like what are you
they're having a great time like maybe
they're having a great time and really
enjoying but i was also having a great
time and enjoying the music right i just
don't scream about it yeah but that's
just but it depends on what it gets
everyone's a little different like i
can't load my oven without my husband
coming up behind me and i'm like are you
serious because he's an animal
so it depends there's something for you
ian that will just awaken this primitive
beast and you'll be like
i wouldn't i don't know i wouldn't i
wouldn't judge that i've seen ian do the
whole night clapping when we showed him
a sheet of graphene his eyes just turned
white
tim cass out of context here we go
i get excited but i guess maybe that
said i don't get overly excited i just
don't get over excited i never have yeah
it makes sense so why freak out
wait let's talk about like the catholic
church i bet you a million bucks we can
get you yelling it was similar like a
church congregation watching people clap
and scream was like watching a bunch of
people concert repeat the show m.c
hammer
fighters
i think uh well dude mc hammer is legit
yeah that was my first time for those
pants
this little kid up on stage i kept
getting up and dancing in the audience
what was your first what was your first
comment yeah yeah that was your first
comment police amber don't hurt him
my first concert was fleta what was it
called fla i think it's pronounced what
is that uh i don't know elvis costello
played that oh that's cool yeah yeah
mine was bruce springsteen at the
meadowlands oh nice so are you guys you
saying that people that cheer and scream
are not inherently stupid
than other people because i look at it
as like a why are you doing that i don't
understand it's their tribal rite of
passage to like scream at local h or
something i don't know okay so it's like
it's tribalism yeah chicago but that to
me indicates like a lack of intelligence
why would you fall for a call
it's a it's a sensory overload
experience maybe they all have autism so
they don't have the eq to handle it and
they just get overloaded and start
yelling or they like it it's like
feeling the spirit of god yeah yeah it's
kind of like that imagine imagine it's
just a crazy trip like i watched a guy i
watched a guy play music and music
that's why i watched the gospel i
watched it
over the weekend so you clap for him
because you want them to know you
appreciate what they're doing so it's
like virtue signaling it's not virtue
signaling it's gratitude if it's their
friends when it's your friend and even
when their stuff sucks you're like yeah
i don't want to distract them i don't do
that to myself like in a baseball game
if they hit the ball and you go yeah if
you scream the people in the outfield
will like shudder and the ball will go
by them so you're a fifth you're like
another player on the team but i don't
that's how you screaming at a guy makes
it better or easier for them no you
taunt them like yeah yeah that's
basically a sports game right
yeah this has nothing to do with with
the fact that people want people peeing
on elevators i think it does it doesn't
very little i i i see a through line of
people that are mindlessly walking
through life i've been to i've been to
shows where the crowd is like the
venue's full and the opening act draws
no movement and no applause they play
and everyone just stands there and
they're like looking and then the main
band comes out and they're like now
we're going to play our number one
single called the magic butterfly and i
was like yeah and they're cheating
because they like the song
it's like
blindly just going like oh we're
clapping like whoever's there i stand
and watch because i like the song it's
not like if you like the song you will
scream you're not the arbiter of
morality and emotion i just i feel like
an outsider i felt like an outsider for
a lot of my life watching people act
very strange and like cults like
what i will say is look i i've cheered
for bands i don't think there's anything
wrong with cheering for a band having a
good time there's a difference though
when you look at mob mentality and like
the summer of love when people were just
running around smashing windows
for just for no reason and they don't
know why they're doing it or when you
know we like
there are people who will uh i remember
who we had on the show they were talking
and saying like it was some lefty guy or
was a liberal guy and he was like i told
my friends i was coming on the show and
they were like why tim pools far right
or whatever and they laughed and they
were like do you watch tim pool and they
were like well no but it's like that's
disturbed someone who's like i have no
idea what that is but i'm angry but
that's that's everybody though i feel
like it's 90 of society anymore it's
really sad
so like you're saying earlier you
thought it was like an emotional
experience at watching a band kind of
like yeah i've taken psilocybin and
cried because it felt so real or great
or whatever but yeah the danger is that
it's the guy on stage that's making you
feel like that or you think it is no
it's the song it's the music or the one
playing it the feeling the scene the
artistic experience like you're
experiencing this when i watched paul
mccartney play hey jude i had a moment
and i rarely have moments but i was
there having my moment i looked over and
there's like this 80 year old dude like
it's my moment too and we had it
together if paul mccartney had been like
now go right if he'd like forced you to
go do something dangerous would you be
more likely to and why why would people
do that why would someone could you
imagine paul mccartney like that song
was called hey jude now everyone you
know burn down a police station
everyone show me your hands
clean hands get your vaccination it's
like that was insane it was insane we
were making fun of a rock concert too i
was at a concert i was at a i was at a
lollapalooza in 1990 kaiser chiefs
that's who they were jane's addiction
playing no that was the previous here
and i went to that one too good but
um smashing pumpkins were playing it was
in west virginia somewhere uh i had
taken a whole bunch of acid and i was
with my friend um and i lost him i don't
know what happened to him i lost my
wallet i lost everything i was tripping
my face off in this crowd 90s experience
yeah i love the 90s
but i had no idea where anything was i
was really entranced by this music i
loved the smashing pumpkins and then um
billy corgan gets out there and he
starts talking about uh we're generation
we're generation nothing
and i looked up and i was like
wow you just totally ruined my vibe i
was having a great time i'm not nothing
like maybe i'm maybe i've lost my
friends and i've lost my wallet and i've
lost my brain but you're you're a fool
like why are you telling a bunch of kids
tripping on athletes
yeah
nothing right but he was having one bad
day and because the call was it was what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was
what
was that here's the thing my point was
my point is i was having a great time i
was having this whole sensory experience
i was not but despite all of that i was
not swayed by his garbage nonsense
i heard this and i was like 94. so if he
had said go get vaccinated i also would
have been like what the hell is wrong
you're a strong mind what about i'm
concerned with the people that pee on
elevators
but those people are going to pee on
elevators no matter what you do but if
someone is always going to be an
elevator period if someone respects
somebody and that person tells you to
pee on the elevator maybe but there's
there's always going to be those people
don't what is the electric fence this is
how you get social credit systems
because the question is like how do we
effectively govern so the people who pee
on elevator buttons aren't ruining
everything for everyone else and they're
like okay we'll create a system
how about if you pee on elevator buttons
you get dropped down to a lower cast and
you have to earn your way out or
whatever to prove you're not going to
pee on elevator buttons that's why they
do it but the problem there is that it
needlessly punishes people and i think
it curtails meritocracy you'll get a
bunch of
smart people who are arbitrarily held
back in a system like that so you're
actually losing out so i think the
reality is there's risk with freedom
comes risk maybe that's what michael
would say something like that we want
freedom that means sometimes you got to
clean piss off elevator buttons
and that's in that's in genesis that's
in the bible like with freedom it is
it's it's you know you know you eat the
apple and then you're gonna have
elevator buttons that's right
where do you what's in there it's like
riding a motorcycle you ask a
motorcyclist why do you do this
dangerous thing they're like i've never
felt more free the wind in their hair
and it's super risky people might not
see you know they die all the time this
is what happens when my mom tells me to
wear a bike helmet which i have never
like i hate buttons does she still do it
today she you put it on your bike yeah i
didn't i didn't live with her until i
was 16 so she didn't have a lot of
opportunity when i was kid
but i'll be like mom
i'm not wearing a bike helmet and you
can't wear me make me she also is always
like are you masking no mom i'm not are
you mad i'm not masking i'll put a mask
on in a store that asks because i'm not
a douche bag i hate when people like wig
out i just don't go in there's doors
yeah i will go to this that i i get but
i've been in a store where they offered
me the mask and i was like i really want
this thing i'm like here you're
protected
whatever like i'm gonna buy this if the
store is like the only one we have to go
there so we were buying computer parts
and we wanted to get like the latest
graphics card or whatever and it's the
only place we can get it on the spot i
was like whatever
but there's there's coffee shops out
here and a local coffee shop had a big
sign saying wear your mask half the
people weren't but i was like starbucks
was literally a hundred feet away so we
went to starbucks instead you guys
brought up the risk of freedom and i'm
thinking about cults and if they're if
we're if they're necessary but they're
just risky because if you get one
dangerous call leader a collar goes
crazy people can do it so we built the
us government the constitution kind of
to make sure that no one cult leader
could arise but now because of social
media um reality tv which we were
talking about before the show it's as if
the cult the power of the cult is
stronger than ever now like cult of
personality they even have a name for it
how
i'm so concerned with it with the rise
of the superstar i mean how do we break
humanities humanity's tendencies to do
human things which is like the leader
episode of the simpsons like everybody
needs that person that doesn't deserve
that adoration and like respect but they
get it anyway oh my god i love i'm just
going to say johnny depp insert name
here anything he says i don't know
that's just what people do that's why
julius caesar coined the mob and was
able to control rome because he's like
dude all i need is mark antony the
people's you know
dude put him on my side and i will own
them and then everybody killed him and
then they tried to do the same thing but
we i mean we used to think that our
leaders were uh descended from god right
we don't think that anymore i think
we've come a long way i like that uh
egypt they all thought that were like
kings of england it's like no they're
just all-in bread the descendant of
their sister's cousins kings of russia
we've come a long way because we don't
have god kings but i'm concerned with
except for jeremy boring but i'm
concerned that
uh that the knowledge will be lost that
that something will happen that there
will be some sort of global revolution
and that everything a bunch of stuff
will get erased and we'll forget i'm
thinking about this a lot recently
because i've been thinking about like
you know the library of alexandria and
how that was burned yeah and just
thinking about it yeah you know we lost
time we lost tons of stuff we lose tons
of stuff constantly so if you think
about it like you know we lost a ton of
stuff from the middle ages we you know
we lost so many manuscripts that were uh
painstakingly copied out by you know
irish monks we've lost a bunch of that
we lose things all of the time we're
losing definitions of words and meanings
of things
yeah i mean we're watching it happen in
real time maybe it's happening faster
now than it was before but it is part of
a perpetual cycle like if you think
about all of the novels that have been
lost that are no longer part of canon
that used to be part of canon at a
certain point no one's going to pay
attention to shakespeare anymore no one
knows how to do handwriting anymore
right we were talking about this before
like if you look at the signatures of
people who grew up without learning how
to how to do cursive
they don't know how to write their names
right it's ridiculous and what was
cursive if not just a technology it was
a technological advancement so that you
could write faster without having
inkblot all over your paper
these are these are technological
advancements they continue to move
forward you know i i think it's
fascinating and i've been i've been
thinking about that recently like what
gets lost how fast do we lose things how
do we how do we know what's important
and shouldn't be lost like if you think
about the invention of the mirror which
we wouldn't have you saw the images of
the
telescope and everything's cool yeah and
if it wasn't for the mirror that was
invented i think in the 1300s we
wouldn't have telescopes
i've been thinking about data storage in
general dude by the way that james webb
hubble tell us or what is james webb
yeah yeah yeah that's a cool image and
it looks like it's spinning like it
captured the universe in mid-spin or
something it's amazing like storing data
in orbit because i feel like we have
servers on earth those things are so
vulnerable if we lost
history like if his man you're right
yeah all those orders
what happened you all got amazing sorry
uh yeah y'all got me thinking civil war
stuff so while you were talking i just
was looking you're always thinking
don't blame us
because we're talking about like this
people in cults mindlessly following
and i started thinking about like what
percentage of people in this country
need to be in a cult before
it goes nuts and it was two percent of
the of the united states that fought in
the civil war the first time two percent
10 enlisted 2 lost their lives so it was
like 620 000 dead i think it was it was
around 3 million people actually
fighting but i looked up
the support and the crazy thing i just
pulled up was that
the north their view of the civil war
i'll read this says many of these
wretched victims are in arms against us
but we are fighting for them
the war for the union and the rights
secured by the constitution is a war for
their social and political salvation and
our victory is their deliverance it is
not against the people of those states
it is against the leaders in the system
which have deprived them of their fair
chances as american citizens that this
holy war is waged god send them and they
go to deliverance you know what's really
crazy about that that sounds like
twitter it sounds like it sounds a lot
like the rhetoric today yes that the
people who are talking about the
constitution freedom
holy war
have probably the same view the
constitution is is going to protect
these people they don't understand
they're being enslaved and tricked by
their leaders and all that stuff and
that's why the union went to war so you
you consider that sentiment along with
the idea that abortion could be the
great moral catalyst
and it very well it sounds very very
similar in terms of ideology and moral
issues
i don't know human beings don't change
that much no this is you know this is
true too if you look at letters home
from the civil war or letters home from
the crusades the what soldiers had to
say to their sisters wives mothers what
have you it's the same throughout
centuries we we just don't change that
much
except for now we'd be like who are they
writing to they keep saying they and
them like how many people is this person
writing to they're married to a lot of
people yeah it's more than one yeah
nobody put like
polyamory of the crusades oh lord right
you know it's kind of if you phase
a contraction apostrophe yes the
apostrophe yeah if you're doing the
singular it's day is day's gone they
become it yeah yeah
okay r is plural is is singular so it
would be you know ezra miller you'd say
they is a dangerous individual accused
of attacking people attacking people
i can't believe the video i saw of him
lifting that chick up by her throat what
yeah
oh i think i saw this took this chick by
her throat no one just decimated
that person i don't even know why we
respect the pronouns of a woman beater
because that's what that guy is he took
this broad by her throat said she was an
overzealous fan i have had so many
overzealous fans did you ever hear that
never
you've never choked any out no
and i even had security guards and i was
like no you're not gonna manhandle them
they're just they're crazy i get it but
you can't you know no roughing people up
get out of here yeah this was june 30th
and then he took he took a chair and
bashed a woman in her face in hawaii and
then when they were trying to bash a
woman in the face do we respect the
pronouns of a woman beating
they changed
the victim just use those pronouns she's
like he was all in my face he was
attacking me my friends were there
vanity fair changed the quote vanity
vanity fair invited jizzling maxwell to
their party yeah so we should we should
definitely listen to what they're
telling i've realized i can't i'm not
going to i don't want to call
corporations the person anymore like
people are like google said that
something's something no someone that
works at google said it i want names
google spokes corporations are people my
friend yeah that's what mitt romney told
me too
i don't like it they'll be like united
democrats are saying like no no no who
said it show me the name and the face
and i want to see their lips move man
i'm tired of like people hiding behind
their corporate yeah corporation will do
something like illegal and then they'll
be like well i guess we have to find the
corporation i'm like no no someone did
something illegal like what would happen
if someone a corporation just killed a
bunch of people and it's like well you
know it was the corporation that
poisoned the people so we can't but
there's a guy who pulls nike he dumped a
oil into that you're like exxon dumped
like no someone did that and someone
caused that yeah but it's not always
just one person i mean at a corporation
it's a lot of different components that
all result in something like that like
if you consider a hr policy for example
that prevents something or other you
know like that's a that's a massive team
effort and dei consultants and ceos and
everybody weighs in yeah but let's say
let's say there's a dude and he's and
the boss goes i want you to pull that
lever right now to turn the machine on
and he goes you got it boss and he turns
the lever on and there's a bunch of kids
on the machine who get crushed instantly
it's like well the corporation did it
who's really at fault it was just a guy
turning the machine on he didn't know
it's like well if you're driving your
car and you close your eyes and hit a
bunch of kids you go to jail well this
is the whole thing about like uh i just
did what i was told is that that's why
it's psychopaths
yeah and like didn't the the hague
decide that doing what you were told
following orders does not count as a
defense yeah yeah but then the issue is
i'll tell you this is a crazy story and
it might be somewhat apocryphal because
i haven't looked into it after the fact
but in turkey there was that coup
attempt all those years ago do you
remember that like six seven years ago
or whatever
what i was told and again very very well
could be wrong but it's an interesting
thought anyway
a bunch of soldiers
low-level grunts were told to guard the
bosphorus bridge from a potential terror
attack
then the media reported it was a coup
attempt and those soldiers were actually
trying to overthrow the government so
random citizens came up grabbed the
soldiers and just beat him and beat him
to death and dragged him through the
streets maybe that's not exactly what
happened maybe it was a good time
whatever i don't i don't know much about
the situation but just think about that
you could be a a low-level enlisted guy
or whatever and then your commanding
officer says we're going on a hiking
trip you know we got a mission take the
boats load them up we're going to go to
this shore then we're going to hike up
here and we're going to plant supplies
and then the media reports that you're a
rogue operation trying to overthrow the
government you're like
what like i was just told to carry this
box i have no idea too bad too bad so
how do you even know if you're following
orders that are that are bad you know
what if they're like oh you're the one
who uh
you were ordered to turn the machine on
why'd you do it i didn't know what the
machine did too bad that's no excuse
like the machine did bad things this is
like in the good place did you guys
watch that show no it was like a pretty
good show but it turned out like uh
there was a point system to get into
heaven and you had to like get a certain
number of points and now it sounds
stupid saying get out yeah yeah but like
you had to you know do a certain you had
to like do good things but nobody was
getting into heaven for a really long
time because there was all this
collateral
consequences to decisions so like if you
buy a tomato at the grocery store you're
actually losing points because it was
harvested by slave labor in some place
or other and then it was shipped using
oil and then all of these various we're
all going to hell we're all going to
hell basically yeah um but that's sort
of that's sort of what i was thinking of
like how do you know when you buy a
tomato that you're doing anything okay
or how do you know that you're not just
contributing to the complete decimation
of another country's economy this is the
one tomato this is what led to the
subjective morality of many of these
post-modernists because they're like
well i guess you just have to choose and
decide your subjective morality because
they embrace it often otherwise it leads
me to nihilism maybe not inherently
leads me to nihilism but i'm like wow if
everything i'm doing is a risk of this
that i'm destroying reality then why am
i even here dude i hit the point where i
was like uh death
in lord of the rings when i'm like
abandon your posts flee flee for your
lives like i'm so over
everything and i'll just say hey
everyone out there
i'm over it i'm over you
i'm over it all right when does it end
have you taken dmt before no apparently
you feel like you're dead while it's
happening and it's like
the worst drug experience yeah so you
realize you realize that nihilism is
inherent in reality you don't have to
seek it it's just there always anyway
yeah you got to be your best friend
right so is good i've puffed on dmt i've
never taken the dmt trip i've never
blasted off i mean i've spent five years
in my life like juggling mushrooms and
lsd like i feel good like i'm all right
i'm just gonna be straight edge now i'm
i'm totally off mentally i don't need to
do it anymore
dmt i think is the unique one something
about feeling like you're dead
terrible
i like to be in control so is life it's
horrific like what i'm eating cows are
you kidding me those things they're
delicious but their eyes
quickly so they don't suffer my son said
the other day he was like if you're not
supposed to eat animals why are they
made of food they're so tasty
well
you guys have heard
my anti-vegan position good rant
so uh i'll try and make it quick if
there's a dude on a farm minding his own
business farming food and then eating it
and then another dude just one day
jumps into the property brutally
creating its own nutrients and just
growing minding its own business not
going anywhere not hurting anybody and
then along comes this groundhog and
destroys it and grano just kills it and
eats it vegans are like oh that poor
groundhog i better not hurt it
what no the groundhog the one just
killed the peaceful libertarian plant
it's an authoritarian invader
so i think to do our part we should be
eating as many critters and animals as
possible to save the plants let me offer
you some
truth so i had a corn field directly
behind my house they did soybeans and
corn and every time they would till the
field it was the apocalypse of injured
animals and i wanted to save them all so
i would pick up i had a rabbit fake leg
jake half his his leg was hacked off
because of the tractors so all these
vegans are like oh look at what we're
doing and it's like a critter
apocalyptic you know massacre for you to
have your soybeans dude so like why are
you virtue signaling over there and i
was the one as a little kid i had pets
cemetery it's full of all the others
that's like the wind farms right like
the wind farms that just destroy the
birds yeah and then also as soon as your
turbine is done you can't do anything
with it those blades are just they just
are there yeah it happens man
hydroelectric's brutal on fish too they
get caught in those turbines yeah very
bad and then just sprays
all right everybody we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the share
with your friends and if you are
outraged the january 6 committee smeared
me you can support our work over at
timcast.com mike after hours show coming
up at 11 p.m yes smash that like button
and here's what here's what i'll say
um let's just prove them wrong we're
going to keep building up tim cast we
are going to call out the lies they
obviously hate the fact that we call
them scumbags i do think it's funny that
they included this innocuous clip of me
reading the news and i've repeatedly
called them scumbag nasty people so i
wonder if it's personal they're like
yeah you call me it's going back i'll
put your clip in my thing even though i
didn't say anything so anyway go to
10ps.com support our work tell them uh
you don't support them but you support
us and let's read some super chats all
right blueheart says the chat has been
personified
uh
hello chat
you sons of
bees
yeah behave yourself especially with my
friend over here i was there for libby
apocalypse you disgusting animals
rocket sauce says tim you should call
your coffee shop woke cup wake up with
woke cup i like that yeah i guess i mean
we're we're against being woke so yeah
christina says adrienne and libby i love
these ladies so much
there you go it's ladies night
all right seth hauser says hey tim why
have you not talked about sri lanka's
people rising against their corrupt
government they kicked their lying and
treasonous government out
we have um i mentioned it a couple times
just i've not done like a dedicated
segment to it but i've mentioned it in
multiple food shortage segments i've
done we've passively mentioned it on
this show a couple times
i don't know i didn't know there was an
uprising like that oh yeah they learned
they burned it they burned
was it your tweet tim that was like this
is an insurrection no no who said that
sri lankan president maybe
maybe maybe maybe it was me i don't know
wow there's a lot of tweets out there
yeah all right heather says tim i need a
way to download content within the app i
have the same issue with daily wires at
i like to listen to stuff at work but i
have awful reception there yes um we
don't even have an app so we're working
on it we're working on getting an app um
i will say people have talked about
listening to the show with the screen
off and you can do it with the brave
browser
but uh we are nowhere near as large as
the daily wire
and we are working on
expanding the website we're uh supposed
to have a big announcement it was
supposed to be today but it just keeps
getting it was fun
and then maybe it'll be tomorrow um
because it's it's we're doing some
interesting practice sounds like q a
personally
um but we got some cool stuff happening
and uh we're also then gonna be working
on tv apps apple tv roku all the stuff
chrome uh iphone android and then we're
gonna we we we're probably gonna be
having like two comedy specials
exclusive for tim cast we're gonna have
a couple new shows launching and then
we're we're also looking at like a
homesteading show so we've got a lot of
stuff we're gonna have a bunch of shows
it's gonna be great it's gonna be good
fun and then instead of being like why
aren't you canceling your disney i'm
just gonna be like well you don't have
to cancel them i don't care but we have
better stuff so stop giving your as the
daily wire says stop giving your money
to people who hate you give it to well
they say give it to them but you can
give it to us too yeah give them i'll
take your money too yeah there you go
we'll all just you know
alms for the poor that's right
raymond g maga stanley jr says tim my
awful aunt texted me that's affluent
white female liberal i saw that tim
person you watch raymond what are you
doing watching people like that i just
laughed and laughed
awful that's awesome good for good for
raymond yeah affluent white female
liberals
yeah that's awesome tim's enemy number
one now well i mean it's like uh
tucker said it you know he's like that's
who i'm mad at yeah he's not wrong right
they're all they're all voting for
democrats regardless of politics so it's
like okay well and they're pretending
that all these horrible things aren't
happening yep because they don't they
just don't believe that it could
possibly be happening because it's so
irrational and stupid yeah
the world it's a normalcy bias no no
that clearly is not true you're a
conspiracy theorist i'm like it's here's
a video you know you know can you can
you just
send your family members the video of
the man turkey working for a little girl
i'm just here you go i'm not kidding be
like here you go watch the video and see
what they say and the amazing thing is
that guy is not fringe
yeah he's mainstream he's legit legit
raymond send your awful aunt that video
just without prompt just send it to her
and then see what she says
and be like what do you think
like don't don't say tim pool don't say
tim cats just be like no no don't even
take this pride be like what are your
thoughts like send the video and then
see exactly what she says because she's
probably gonna be like what are you
sending me and why
and it'll be like oh
i i figured you'd like this you know
criticizes these videos did you see the
guy who tried to read a book in front of
a school council meeting they didn't
even let him read the first word they're
like just so you know we have kids who
are watching at home and i cannot allow
you to read this pornographic material
he's like this is in the library
psychopaths the woman they threatened to
kick out if she kept reading the book in
the school curriculum yeah yeah
the you know you know i got to say
raymond you're awful and as a conspiracy
theorist
i'm not exaggerating i'm not trying to
be cute i'm saying quite literally these
are people who live in this bubble world
of weird yeah blue and non-conspiracy
nonsense like what what these people are
saying the january 6 committee to me
it's queuing on it's the exact same
thing trump was trying to overthrow the
government
it's the same as people who are like
he's the real president i'm like dude
it's dick cheney's daughter guys
democrats
dick cheney's daughter oh but she's so
amazing and we trust her so much oh i'm
like what land am i living in it is very
peculiar yeah it's so weird like people
i've known my whole lives they're like
well you know because she's saying
things i like i'm like it's the uniparty
of course she's saying things yeah
halliburton is telling you what to do
well the establishment is the
establishment we've got a a celebrity
here in the super chat oh my god peter
peter he says sniff that like button oh
no
don't do it if you like what it smells
like click the bell oh
come on man that's good
all right
uh oh we're getting some comments about
livy wow adam c says tim you need to get
la modern artist louis
uh uh carry on is that everybody carry
on on your show he loves your show and
told me he'd love to come on he is
fighting the culture war and cali how do
i set it up uh i guess email lydia spin
the ufo at gmail.com
uh og
mamacita bear says not family friendly
when libby is here
sorry fellas
all right let's see you can listen to it
it's fine too snolorum says you
completely missed the point on the nyc
psa it wasn't about nuclear war
preparedness it was about that little
subliminal bit of listen to and trust
the media that's in there towards the
second half of the video i did see that
and that's what they were like stay
tuned to the media so you can know if
the nukes are coming oh yeah probably
yeah step three is keep watching us keep
our ratings up
you read the new york times you're a
conspiracy theorist but you are they
publish fake news and then have to
retract it like a day later they keep
doing it like every single time
but i i did i looked up the sarmat ii
nuke yes that's satan two they call it
nato calls it satan too
but one one nuke would wipe out like new
england
one
so it's a 50 megaton payload 10 heavy
merv warheads yeah i did some research
on hypersonic stuff it goes up into
orbit it can turn and change directions
not on a dime i said yesterday kind of
misrepresenting its agility the sarmat
ii russian nuke they've just tested
they're prepared to deploy is a
fractional uh orbit bombardment system
meaning it only goes about 150
kilometers not
not 1200 so it's got no early detection
it it goes under the radar so these
things they hit
so many weapons we could wipe out the
earth how many times a thousand times
what are those pills you're supposed to
take during potassium iodide yeah i
brought that up to my husband and he's
like babe we just got nuked you you you
want to live through that i'm like oh
yeah he's like screw those pills you
will no no no no no no no no hold on i
want to lift you let me break it down
for you no one's nuking montana where i
live the potassium ions
moose potassium iodine don't protect you
from a radiation blast yeah no they
protect you from ingesting radioactive
particles particles which will cause
thyroid cancer so the question is when
you do survive the nuclear blast and
radioactive iodine is in the air and
you're like i don't need those pills
then you'll die a slow death from cancer
over 10 years aren't we all going to do
that anyway
you'll both be sitting there with big
necks being like it was worth it i plan
on my consciousness being in a machine
at that point
you're going to do the upload you would
do it
dude i'm job from the lawnmower man the
way that i got really interested in
transhumanism is i was like yeah i want
to live forever i was like so entranced
by these ideas that i was like
the idea of you lived
well your if your consciousness is can
you really upload your consciousness no
what is the dividing you're talking
about your soul you're look it's
fascinating your facebook account it's
just it has all the data for them to
create an aiu and you will talk to
yourself about that's not me what's
going on and then they'll walk up to you
and they'll plug your brain into a
computer and then all of a sudden there
will be a robot version of you being
like i'm a better you i'm more perfect
to you and then it like snaps your neck
and how you're going i forgot that and
then
then you'd look like the people in polar
express right
all right this is important when we got
my miles and says hey tim i had my
monthly payment taken via paypal on
monday for the members-only content i
went in and watched the landau after
show and it won't let me in the contact
us form doesn't work either
um members timcast.com
yeah so uh i apologize for this guys
it's it's an issue that we've been
working to resolve like i mentioned we
have a big announcement so i can't say
too much but uh this is one of the
things we're working to resolve with
paypal that it's just
i don't know what to tell you like
there's problems so uh we're doing our
best to correct all of this and to get
it all fixed so i again apologize
hopefully tomorrow we have the big
announcement which is a better solution
to all of this and it's going to be big
news and really awesome it was supposed
to be today i guess it's not it's pushed
back maybe it'll be tomorrow i don't
know
um but uh i i appreciate the support
we'll do our best to get it fixed and
man i in the meantime we just like we're
we have 30 employees and so we have to
go in and keep fixing this problem
because um truth be told we have a lot
of members and it happened faster than
we realized we built the system and then
what we didn't know is there was this
thing the glitch that happens after a
year so everyone who signed up at the
exact same time was like 10 000 people
then a year later all of a sudden we get
slammed by this weird glitch that we had
no idea was going to happen and it was
just like we had to hire hire people and
do all this crazy stuff to get sorted so
apologies but we got into high gear and
so we should have a big announcement
soon where we're fixing this in a very
very cool way uh in the meantime for
those of you that haven't seen the dave
landau episode i seriously think it's
like one of our funniest because the
dude's hilarious and we had jamie
killstein who's also hilarious
and we were just being rude and funny
and dave had some really great jokes in
there so it was really really good
beautiful man i love you dave good to
meet you man he's awesome sunny sabranti
saying the same thing uh subscription
was incorrectly made inactive
yeah it's this weird glitch that hits it
once like your one year mark or
something like that and so the
anniversary yeah happy anniversary guys
so
sending him super chats all your money
to complain
we we we we have members at timcast.com
where you can send in and we people like
they respond as fast as we can but when
we get hit with this weird glitch all at
once it's like we respond as fast as we
can a lot going on yeah so uh apologies
for that we'll get it fixed as soon as
possible and then again hopefully
tomorrow this will solve everything and
y'all will be very excited
so
uh yeah it's time to become a member or
you know
see what happens tomorrow or else
sign up you gotta check out that landau
episode it's crazy it's really good cal
smith says for the beautiful femcast i
guess tim and ian are okay too
thank you
brad smith says at some point the
millennials will be in charge will they
be authoritarians yes yes yes the
millennials are totally authoritarian
that's a generalization as millennials
start taking over we see more psychotic
authoritarianism i see a lot of it it's
this this because it's because the
chemicals in the in the i don't know my
bloodstream i don't know why i think
it's because they all they all just
drank the kool-aid i think they're
narcissists they want you to bend the
knees
the millennials are the true heirs to
the boomers
did you see the solution rogan told me
it was psilocybin like if people don't
like they need to break open their third
eye so that they don't know a lot of
these a lot of these people went to
college and did all of that stuff while
they were there you know it just doesn't
matter they want you to mask up and
boost and do what you're told and be
really proud of it there's a meme of a
guy with purple hair up against a wall
with a bunch of other people and there's
a communist soviet guy and he says hey
comrade when do we get free health care
they think when the revolution happens
that they the bourgeoisie will be the
ones leading the charge they don't get
it these millennials are the bourgeoisie
they're not the proletariats no they're
not the there's a video from seattle of
dudes and construction hats chanting
down awful affluent white female
liberals and their weird colleges
that's hysterical
those those construction guys that's the
proletariat yeah you're the bourgeois
and they don't understand that that when
the revolution comes they are the ones
up against them yeah but they suffer so
much as they sit in their amazing dorm
room mommy and daddy pay for in there
yeah they've been oh my god my apple it
cost so much i'm so depressed oh that
was the most infuriating thing to me
growing up all the people who are like i
need to get a macbook and i'm like dude
a pc
for one third of the cost has the same
power and they're like but max are
better
see yeah i'd be like i want this someone
that my dad was like
hold out both hands one one poop in the
other yeah
my son was like mom i don't want a mac
just get me this pc that's like yeah i
know he's waiting
my mom was like go to the thrift store
there's a computer for 20 bucks
and then i was really excited like i
built my own computer it was crazy i was
like eight when i built my first
computer because it's not hard i wasn't
allowed to have video games and stuff
growing up i was playing jez ball
remember that no what is that jazz ball
yeah and there was another game i can't
remember and then i got warcraft one
you know what i had when i was a kid i
had an atari and it had that fake wood
paneling on it wow yeah the 2600 yeah
yeah i had one of those too i think my
dad had it eldest brother had that when
it was a little girl there was the oh my
gosh a little penguin that jumped over
ice holes in a glacier i used to play
that that's where you have to jump from
ice to ice and like up and down that
game frostbite yes let's read some more
we got hot normative says youtube is
blocking me from super chatting the name
but new music out by tyson james about
the big guy stream on youtube buy on
itunes and amazon very interesting okay
cool
we've got a bunch of music in the works
and a couple of them are are nearly done
bangers yeah i'm really excited that we
got pete parata formerly of the
offspring doing the drummers uh doing
being the drummer uh uh for us which is
really exciting i'm really grateful
doing the drummers sounded funny
that's next year yeah it's gonna get
crazy stay tuned
yeah but it's crazy because uh there's
like a song that i wrote when i was 14
that we recorded recently and it's just
i got a bunch of really old songs and it
was when i was just like covering the
offspring's little kid and i was
thinking about today i was like a song i
wrote when i was 14 when i was like
spamming all the offspring albums and
like heavily inspired by leatherwork i
now have like their old drummer who's
working with me to make this song that's
like a weird thing to happen that's just
really cool that's pretty cool you rock
man i'm a big fan this is really great
stuff his drumming is absolutely
fantastic whenever i ever get start to
get black-pilled i think about that like
you you were hanging out with our idols
now like that's reality now is it so
connected and you're so able to jack in
that you can
befriend the people that you used to
look up to it's really so cool yeah
billy corgan signed a poster for me that
was super exciting i was like wow man
tell him he really ruined my trip in
1994 in west virginia well i don't
really i don't like talk to him i met
him like a friend of a friend i met him
at the playboy mansion
and we told all the playmates because
they were too young to know who he was
that he was michael stipe from rem and
they believed it
and they would come up to him like oh my
god i love shiny happy people and he's
looking at me and i'm like this is great
that was great it was awesome
uh i'd love to have billy on or to come
hang out so probably gotta reach out
let's read some more
super chats
howard says roll in 20s looking into the
air wtf stays strong big news coming on
the vatican god created the universe and
it's the age of aquarius enlightenment
here we go big news
it is the dawning of the age of aquarius
apparently i'm told yeah it's like the
year 2450 is when it begins or something
like that so they were couple hundred
years out they were singing that song
age of aquarius before the age of
aquarius
yeah of the age of appearances
yeah in the year 2250 i think when the
age goes from the age of pisces to the
age of aquarius i don't believe in any
of that crap i don't even know what that
means well it's real it's just whether
you believe in the spirituality of it it
basically means that i think the axis is
pointing at pisces
something called the procession of the
equinox where the axis rotates around
the
uh celestial constellations or whatever
i wonder if age of pisces metaphorically
was like that was the age of the
fisherman where we live on the coast
yeah the age of the fish and that and
jesus teach amanda fish all this fishing
fishing in the future is going to be the
age of the water bearer who's aquarius
and it's going to be get find water
yeah desalination water water water
water we'll be using it as fuel we'll be
able to convert it into food it's going
to be crazy what we can do with water or
we'll be able to mix it with carbon i
think we're going to have a shortage of
it before we figure out amazing things
to do but it is like hundreds of years i
think after the the rise in the fall and
the rise and the fall and the rise
whatever happens what we do
all right let's what's uh let's grab
some more
sean me says damn those were some
powerful memes the pen is mightier than
the sword and the meme might be mightier
than both i think so yeah absolutely
there was i saw a leftist meme you know
leftist memes are like verbose so bad
and it was verbose and it was like
right-wing memes and it showed like i
mean and then it said left-wing memes
and it showed the dude from uh monsters
inc and it said leftist memes have to
take the time to explain very complex
ideas and deep brainwashing because
you've been brainwashed by by you know
the media and the corporations you don't
realize
right-wing memes are very simple because
it's pandering to your baser instincts
and i'm just like oh here we go
yeah my favorite meme is it's a little
guy that says pray for me as i undertake
this arduous journey to read this
leftist meme yeah it's always like three
pages long yo sergeant r6 says shout out
to the ups guy in north east pa that
just dropped off a box with this show
blaring in his truck yeah yes what up
super cool last time i was on here my
ups came up to me and they're like yeah
fight the fight i love you
i'm
all right what do we got
albie dam says ian technically there was
a self-proclaimed emperor that lived in
san francisco named joshua norton he
proclaimed becoming an emperor in 1859.
oh my god good for him turned out for
him for josh josh
isn't there like an independent area in
nevada where some guy declared
independence in the government sounds
like nevada but then he was like
they said are you going to pay your
taxes and he goes no but i will pay a uh
what he called it like a tithe or like
um
aid to the u.s government in the form of
you know these percentages or whatever
kind of whatever
yeah they're like okay whatever you're
not wrong joshua abraham norton emperor
norton the first oh my
that's solid
self-proclaimed cool picture
blankenstein's monsters has canceled fox
nation subscription and subscribed to
the tim cass nation elf the mainstream
media let the media revolution begin wow
i really appreciate it that's awesome i
i heard that uh not a lot of people
don't really watch fox nation yeah tim
cass is bigger i think i'm a huge fan of
kennedy man we have a decent amount of
subscribers we're nowhere near as big as
like the daily wire or anything like
that but i have to imagine fox nation's
got to have hundreds of thousands of
people or something right is it
different like tucker exclusive yeah
yeah it's like it's it's special shows
you can only get on fox nation
subscription subscription service
you know what i thought was funny we
were like if we do like exclusive shows
what do we call it like everyone just
calls their thing plus and i'm like
don't do plus no i'm like why don't we
just call it tim cast yeah it's like the
show's available at tim cast it's
exclusive that's way better yeah it's
it's like you don't need a plus isn't
that weird though everyone does that i
hate the plus i know i was like minus
yeah that's right
or just like that is there a neutral
symbol what is it just put an umlaut
over it yeah
[Laughter]
all right powder pz says women working
doubled the labor force decreasing the
value of each individual worker so now
you need two incomes to have a family
that is correct that's right
that's really funny i love when the left
shows this chart where it's like
salaries uh wages by year and then
around 1979 it just tanks and keeps
going straight and they're like i wonder
what happened and then it's like women
entered the workforce yeah
you know stopped raising their kids and
now look at them yep
that's that's the thing too they don't
want it kids are a disaster look at us
all they don't want to hear it but
if you double the workforce overnight
competition becomes insane among the
workforce
and now people need two incomes it's an
employer's market yeah yep
and then what happens is the government
says okay we'll pay for the daycare with
with great schools
right and we'll indoctrinate your kids
yeah for free for free
for free
no it's not free we're going to take
your money to a doctor that's right it's
a win-win for us yeah this is the crazy
thing it's like someone walks up and
they're like i think parents should have
the right to choose where they where
their kids go to school and the left was
like no that's bad
right that's well it's it's the left
says that's okay so long as you're
really wealthy like if you're really
wealthy you can choose where you want
your kids to go to school it's the
weirdest thing i was like wouldn't it be
good if like poor areas were able to
send their kids to better schools and
they're like
no keep those poor people can they keep
their victims that they can keep using
for all their stuff the thing that's
crazy about the school choice thing too
is it's like
so many of the people that are
advocating against school choice just
send their kids to private school
yeah you know
like i went to private school and like
people i know
there were opposed to school choice you
know what i mean like so yeah all right
we got bad adam 12.
bad adam says adrienne do you still
collect vintage avon bottles i have some
i'd like to send you if you are
interested do you have any contact
information if not no worries i've never
collected vintage avon bottles who's
telling
us
wrong
i've never heard of that before i mean i
sell avon but i don't collect bottles
like what am i gonna do with them
collect them
says tim is constantly saying things are
imploding or a civil war is coming i i
uh
would say i'll agree but when will the
straw break and when will the first
steps happen they probably already did
and so i'll put it this way
um it's really fascinating
the idea of when the civil war started
it's like fort sumter and i'm like
really though was it really wasn't the
secession the start of the civil war but
even then really wasn't bleeding kansas
right where did it really start the the
issue is that it was always happening
this conflict and it boiled over to
where we say okay what now people are in
the shooting each other so that's the
war right and it's like
uh bleeding kansas i think was seven
years
and it only it never actually stopped it
just became part of the greater national
civil war
so
when when are things going to happen i
don't know january 6th
like that was i'm sorry it was the
stupidest day of my life
and it just won't end the stupidity
everything 5 29 day yeah 5 29. that was
insane i was watching all the live feeds
of that i can't believe people don't
look at that as worse but this is like
the bleeding kansas phase
intermittent violence and ideological
clashes
and now you know we read the sentiment
from the north i read it because it was
fascinating the idea that the left is
being manipulated by their leaders and
we need to ensure the constitutional
rights of even the people in those
states i'm like wow that's that's crazy
right
that's what they were believing
apparently they actually formed a
central bank in order to handle the
civil war those i think was 1860 186
1863 one of those one of those years
right around there that's when they set
up a central bank basically like what
they're trying to do now with the
digital currency the usbc's these u.s
bank central
currency whatever
yeah it's it's similar
economic
peril that's for sure
no it's not it's just we just got to
figure out how to get things from place
to place a lot easier with less cost
i'm talking about cost of energy vhs2
says the us air force minuteman 3 might
only launch with 1.47 145 kiloton
warhead the u.s navy trident 2 can
launch with a 12 475 kiloton warhead
interesting
but i still think i don't know the us
hasn't announced anything nearly as
powerful as the sarmat too that thing's
massive
a 50 megaton payload that's nuts man at
some point bigger is not better you want
like more insidious you want something
that breaks apart and gets into the
cells you know louis
louis cordova's plan it's funny how
three women are talking about baking and
having a beautiful time and you got tim
and ian screaming like apes and talking
about missiles that's special
traditional roles
matter
and
my handwriting is a weird mix like you
know you know the the the spongebob meme
where are you
yeah we do like lowercase that's how i
actually write you know i had i don't
know why you have a chaotic brain yeah
it's just like it's like
too much on your plate and that's a
reflection of it
i think i actually did well right here
yeah there's no capitals that's great
tim's paper like cursive i wouldn't do
it it was the one thing in school i just
would never i was terrible at it and so
i got held after school for like weeks
in what was essentially handwriting
detention
and mr belmore um made me learn how to
do cursive there were a couple other
kids there we were all pretty miserable
yeah but now i can write in christmas i
remember very distinctly because i i
circled my o's and a's too many times
we've got a very very important super
chat
we'll grab we'll grab one more
mason
lou allen says been trying to torrent
the hunter by the material i concede but
can't download can your organization
commit to downloading and combing this
material love what you do no
you know why
because
we have risen to believe that the
material is actually illegal
which is funny so a news organization uh
we don't have the legal apparatus to to
to do anything like that uh but hunter
biden who actually has the material and
the feds know about it uh he's not in
jail no
interesting yeah uh do you think project
veritas would be able to do something
like that i don't know man look at the
ashley biden thing yeah that didn't end
too well
we don't have the wherewithal for any of
that deep stuff so i always tell people
like if you've got these big things you
like go to veritas because they have the
legal ability and wherewithal to do this
and we and with the realities we don't
i'm not going to lie and pretend like
we're trying to create a newsroom we're
trying to build this company up the more
members we get the stronger we become in
defending ourselves and being able to go
after this stuff i would say
the daily wire could probably handle it
i don't know if they have the same kind
of news apparatus that we do they're
doing more movies shows but they do have
news out a newsroom
uh we would probably need
we would need to be or like comparable
to daily wire and size to be able to
handle an endeavor like that because you
do you even want to look at that crap
kind of to expose them and call them out
and reveal the stuff to the public yes
but this is such extreme stuff you need
like powerful legal apparatus none of
the people who support bidem will care
you can show him
videos it doesn't matter that the guy
could like murder their own mother and
they'd be like yeah but trump said and
you're like he just killed your mom yeah
but orange man yeah all right well
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel hit
that little notification bell icon and
become a member at timcast.com we are
gonna have a special after hours show
tonight we do this monday through
thursday exclusive on the website and uh
we would love to see you there as we
talk about things that your kids
probably shouldn't listen to because we
get you know it's uncensored so uh check
out timcast.com you can follow the show
at timcast irl you can follow me
personally at timcast adrian do you want
to shout anything out uh
i'm on the internet under my name if you
want to find me oh i activated my
twitter after
two years you can find me there
instagram i have a website facebook i'm
on truth social oh and they can also
find you in the tim cast irl chat room
oh yeah yeah sometimes i troll you
people
but i still like you
even though i talk
poop yeah poop yeah all right
ah i'm on twitter at libby evans i'm on
instagram
as well and i'm at the post millennial
every day you can check us out find me
at ian crossland.net if you want to get
in touch with my social media accounts
and if you don't have a glass of water
go grab one now after the show and
chug that thing tonight get healthy
hydrate it's good for you fix let your
shoulders back drop back let your chin
down you know good posture man see you
later very good sage advice from ian
there thank you guys very much for
tuning in to this lovely ladies night we
should have that every tuesday evening
we should have hilarious guys on monday
and nothing but ladies on tuesday i
think that's the perfect balance the
best combination you guys can follow me
on twitter mines.com at sourpatchlitz as
well as sourpatchlids.me we will see you
all at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out bye guys
you